you
whoa
you guys are here I didn't notice you
there hey guys welcome to the H3 podcast
oh yeah all right all right it's Friday
December 9th
[Applause]
[Laughter]
is a threat to me this happened wasn't
hot yeah he's got it you know when dogs
bark and their butthole doesn't it yeah
yeah I do that too when you bark when I
bark
so today we are sponsored by Shopify who
we love
and today we are going bye
how do you even introduce her Brittany
Broski Adele Meghan Trainor
[Applause]
uh everybody is looking forward to the
great comeback of Brittany Broski our
first episode is a fam favorite
and uh I'm so happy to have you here we
have a great episode planned and I'm
sure that we are gonna have so much
freaking fun dude I would have to agree
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah good to be back
thank you guys yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and IL is
behind here today
yeah nice to see you we're going on a
actually to it's almost Ila's birthday
and we're going on a little trip yep
where you going the Grammy Museum should
we stay or is it okay to say or not
it's a remote spot I don't think they
would ever figure it out but like people
are weird yeah they are I'm always when
I go to Disney I want to post real time
but I'm like you'll regret it yeah it's
like I wanna
they give me a Coke Zero for free thank
you yo Disney oh us I was like yo Disney
gives you Coke Zero no you did can I get
a Coke Zero in solidarity you guys
whenever I go to you want one I'll take
one yeah yeah solidarity it's [ __ ]
delicious
that was Wendy Williams by the way one
more time Zach
she farted and burped and then shocked
herself
you want to watch this James oh I've
seen it okay okay what was that James
what was that yeah
God she was waiting I missed her yeah
she was a big one to me she was really
important yeah hey Gabe whoa are you in
New York
[Applause]
Big Apple Gabe what's going on
in the world and it's Friday baby
the greatest city in the world what you
doing in New York
they got some stuff we got to do we're
supposed to have it we're supposed to be
in New York for my birthday but
this will make it up buddy let's say
[ __ ] yeah
wait what do you wait what are you guys
doing in New York
I got some friends we gotta okay
yeah you're in Manhattan what it looks
like you're in can I guess what street
you're on hmm what is it that looks like
I gotta say I think that's 73rd I don't
think that's 52nd 57 73rd Street you're
in the upper west side right
well somewhere around the area
have you been to New York
yeah Gabe I haven't talked to you since
we missed your birthday party and I'm so
sorry but I do want to assure you Gabe
that we've all been ABS we've been
ravaged and punished by Gabe's birthday
occurs so please let please let us off
the hook for that
okay thank you buddy all right thank you
yeah Brittany do you want to ask Gabe
anything since he's here White Cloud
Gabe Gabe how's the smog in New York
right now okay there's no smog in New
York let's go
oh yeah
can you ask can we get you to ask the
passerby or something
what is it so so New Yorkers hate Los
Angeles I've learned that yeah so let's
ask the New Yorkers hey what do you
think about Los Angeles and let's see if
let's see what they say well just a man
on the street you're just asking
questions I'm curious yeah all right say
are you a New Yorker first let's confirm
that they're a New Yorker well actually
they don't have to be they still hate it
right
baby awesome lady right here whoa
how you doing are you a New Yorker
trouble here dude yeah yeah people
aren't down okay all right that means
she's in New York yeah I think she was I
think she was a New Yorker okay I don't
want to do that you don't want to get
out of here yeah that's fine that's
understandable I wouldn't either I won't
force you to do anything you're not
comfortable with but how is the Friday
vibe in New York compared to L.A
that's great okay
more energy it's it's all it's like the
weekend you can't even notice it you
didn't even notice that [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
[ __ ]
all right Gabe I'm gonna let you go
enjoy your birthday weekend there and I
want to say [ __ ] in my dick hole [ __ ]
get my dick
do you want to try something vulgar
something about shooting in any orifice
like [ __ ] in my [ __ ] [ __ ] out of my ass
and give me pink eye and then butterfly
kiss me [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right we love you buddy okay enjoy
New York all right all right baby
[ __ ]
hasta la vista
is so funny
foreign
wow
White Club game everybody classic
he's on Cameo you guys could you know if
you want birthday wishes what a pleasant
surprise yeah he's he's the best wow so
um like I was saying we have a such a
fun episode here today oh I want to say
just a quick show note there's no show
on Monday regarding what we were talking
about for Ila's birthday the Monday
episode is being moved to Tuesday so
we're going to be doing the full uh
roster we're just moving one over all
right
little housekeeping yeah a little
housekeeping
um
real quick too sorry I'm so sorry about
this there's a lot of housekeeping I'm
just going you should have to come in
after you did all this yeah you want to
leave and come back I'll sit here pay
fresh.com December uh collections
yeah check it out there's all this [ __ ]
I'm wearing this right now the ladies
told me to unbutton it because I looked
like I was wearing a moo moo
you know
I like the little the teddy bear ear
beanie oh yeah right Ariana Grande of
you iconic and so this is what it is go
check it out I'm wearing that iridescent
dress right there never mind oh it's
gone well they can see it on you yeah
okay so I want to show you oh yeah
that's that's what I look like in my
mumos I always was this was one of my
favorite episodes of Simpsons yeah and I
feel I identify with the MooMoo yeah
because Comfort overall listen let me
tell you something this episode he gets
super fat and he starts wearing a
movement for Comfort because let me tell
you something when you get out of the
shower when your gonads are hanging and
you're free and all you do is put on a
moon you go straight to you know like
one of those little sleeping gowns with
the little candle and a little funny hat
in a moomoo it doesn't matter gender
that's going to be the best sleep you
ever have are you dry or do you dry in
the MooMoo oh no you dry off okay
because you were like water moo moo
sleep be dripping wet
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta
completely dry off do whatever skincare
you got to do put the MooMoo on I'm
telling you man everyone needs to free
ball in a moo moo I have to say I never
tried a moomoo you should do it Dan can
you order a muumu a 2XL please yep
or three maybe I don't know probably not
three that's a bit much not that [ __ ]
fat I'm on it
get me a sleeping bag with uh holes in
it please for my arms suggest Mumu
dresses for women how about from well if
it's for women yeah 3XL yeah
um we wanted to show this off by the way
we bought this towel for a sketch wait
this is 15 bucks
I guess that's a lot when you look at it
we were looking at your broken merch
what do you think about this Joe Rogan
sells this towel on his official website
because conquer your inner [ __ ] yes he
does this is official merch website but
wait bring out the towel because this
was funny on its own but once we got the
towel we realized how [ __ ] funny it
is is it just shitty quality or is it
you're gonna love it you're gonna love
it okay
I literally want to make a Joe Rogan
Joker jerk Joe Rogan jerk earlier okay I
was saying off camera that they need to
have Cody Noel on again and I want to be
on the episode but I'm not going to talk
I'm just going to sit right there I
don't have a mic I'm just reacting
um I would you could do the same with
Joe Rogan and I wouldn't be on camera
but I don't want to be off camera and
just be like this judging I want to see
a woman to scorn I love that that feels
such a good idea can I come yeah yeah
we'll hold hands the whole time are you
available
um to just sit in all of our podcast
tiny little bleacher yeah one person
Caleb Presley with Barstool his little
show oh he's so funny he's so [ __ ]
funny I love him he that's character I
forget his name but he just sits in the
background and eats he's just like a big
guy those two guys are so funny we're so
I won't go on it so bad I don't know if
you know who they are an interview
format that was me I'm sorry he does it
it's like short form interview it's kind
of like Zach Galifianakis but between
two friends but he's got his he's got
his own thing
he's like he did one with post Malone
and guys what's up with the towel
he kind of wrote them like he he roasts
them but at the same time it's so
light-hearted and funny and then big ass
always plays a lot they just crack up
it's so good yeah all right well as we
went for the towel well Cody and well
um let's make it happen yeah I'm putting
in the request Broski Nation request
well okay they can't find the towel but
it turns out it's literally like a
washcloth
oh like a tiny one it's tiny
tight it's a teeth
with a [ __ ] two by two inch towel
it's got really lace edges
super soft Bro [ __ ] you first for
sensitive skin the microfiber Joe Rogan
towel it's like a little face cloth
face cloth it's so small but maybe we'll
find it so Random [ __ ] you Joe Rogan for
bro guys oh we got it we've got it all
right fly in the tea towel
towel
[Laughter]
so there it is it's like that shitty uh
so why is it wet by the way
I know it was like my Gucci sweat
that'll do it does a lot of damage it's
one of those shitty like red bubble
print ones too you know it was clear he
was like I want to put this on it and
then just got the cheapest towel good
for him so when people exercise did they
carry a towel with them is that what
this is foreign
[Music]
if you say that to a woman it comes off
the wrong way I'd be like yeah it comes
off the wrong way [ __ ] yeah you just
tell me the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you need to be more masculine what does
that mean you [ __ ] so what does that
mean it doesn't come off right I
literally have a vagine and what so
do women watch Joe Rogan I think that's
what it means that they don't yeah they
don't you know what I wanted to watch
Miley's clips from when she went on it
and I refused to watch it on his channel
I watched like Tick Tock uploads of it
yeah like because [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
know you talk to your inner [ __ ] don't
make that hurt on it on a daily basis I
conquer my inner [ __ ] it really that
you conquer Your Inner Man Child because
you obviously have Arrested Development
because your dad didn't kiss you on the
lips
I didn't do that what did we react to
that last time that picture of who
kisses uh Gary Gary yeah
oh yeah you saw that I love that yeah
that's really great I feel like we
single-handedly turned that into an
internet meme because Cameron Cameron
pulled that out of the of the Vault yeah
my phone really my friend was a big
garyvee fan and it was I think I know
that small like 10 000 viewed video and
he's pulled me aside and said check this
out hey guys thanks for the image bro
this really helps
[Laughter]
glad we got a big screen here you go
that [ __ ] is so ridiculous well that's
how and that's why they're like that
because they didn't get to make out with
their dad a glass of wine
it's beautiful over a nice arugula salad
nice red
is the man
and uh also Joe Rogan is the man here he
is Conquering oh you know what it is
he's so short this is a full body tell
for him
that makes sense those edits of drinks
they do this to Drake It's the funniest
[ __ ] ever we can pull some of those off
you okay all right chill Joe and take a
joke
Joe a survey from 2020 says that Joe
Rogan's audience is 29 women
it seems high that seems wildly
inaccurate it's got well that's 2020 so
it's like almost two years ago so also
Ethan that survey is from the company
that says we're the number 12 podcast of
the world so I I feel it
very beautiful this company is known for
accuracy okay but it is
T so who is he still the number one
podcast
you fart it's crazy yeah so many
[ __ ] listen to that [ __ ] that's
wild
I think he gets like 10 million views
per episode I and it makes me wonder
like because I don't watch it obviously
do y'all watch it I've I've watched a
bit here and there with people I'm
interested is it interesting intriguing
conversation or is it just like they get
high and it's just Chad's so it is good
when he has good guests he he actually
is a good interviewer I think for the
most part when he has good guests and he
gets a lot of really great guests right
then then they have good conversations
but but like lately he's had more and
more political oh my God
how do you do that
I felt the force of that
um sorry yes so so more and more he's
having like political hacks on and like
kovid Miss info freaks great that [ __ ]
is crazy dude that's and that gets the
views too you know who Matt Walsh is no
he had him on recently and that dude is
like the most [ __ ] biggest piece of
[ __ ] ever he's like Andrew Tate but like
beta is [ __ ] I don't know how to
describe him no oh here we go
not in the teddy Prince shirt yeah this
is why y'all have stunt uh Arrested
Development dang
um okay so here's something I wanted to
show you guys now we
regularly gauge the terribleness of
tattoos okay Ela is particularly
passionate about this in fact just to
bring you up to speed ela's Undisputed
worst tattoo of all time is benefit
tattoo oh you're not a fan no no you've
seen it I've oh I've seen it oh I think
it's Modern Art
it's performance art that is performance
art [ __ ]
like what is going on with the picture
collection back there it's me
and you know you know that he at first
like lied about it being a real tattoo
he said that it was for a movie or
something oh yeah because he was
humiliated
it's black and white that [ __ ] is color
yeah how long it takes to like get the
shading right God what a legend and so
but yeah the best part is that he lied
about it but I don't know I don't hate
it as much as Ila I think it's fine do
you actually think it's bad like I'm
genuinely yeah I think it's really
[ __ ] ugly okay okay but I think that
the fact that he committed and got it is
so slay
but like technically it's not that bad
like the artist has talent well what is
it is it a dragon is it it's a phoenix
everything about it like he's not that
guy I don't know and then he yeah like
if you see him from the front he always
wears like I don't know he looks like a
J crew kind of guy like sure just kind
of like yeah that is the human
embodiment of a mullet business in front
oh that's the ovonne yeah
like it has personality I feel like and
he comes off as very like straight yeah
and then like you see this oh and you
know what he's what married to JLo JLo
has to look at that what do you think
wow yeah I do wonder what she thinks
about it I bet she loves it she loves
him when she's pegging him it must be
really distracting right I'm just saying
I don't know yeah so anyway so that's
the that's Ila's moment but then I feel
like I found one that's worse okay
recently now Brendan Schaub by the way
nothing wrong with being pegged I'm just
saying that's working for the best
visibility exactly for the peg community
that is we love we love the picture I
love pegs yeah
our hands like a pirate you wanna know
something recently I got what somebody
said I recently got diagnosed with
sciatica what that is it sounds cool
I wish you have like a cyborg
um your sciatic nerve at the base of
your spine can get pinched I know and
that nerve runs down the entire back of
your leg down to like the bottom of your
feet and so mine was pinched only on my
right leg and it was numb for literally
like three weeks excruciating pain
because I fly and drive for a living so
I'm always sad so it was just like
nothing would alleviate the pain anyway
um I would walk like I had a pig it was
dead all the time and I was like this is
kind of like Vibe it's kind of a Vibe
feeling very piratey you stand out for
sure yeah but wait how do you what do
you do about it it just comes and goes
you just have to take Ibuprofen wow I
went to the doctor and I was like well I
can't feel the bottom of my foot and my
knee hurts and my background my butt
cheeks numb and he was like
and he was like we'll see if this works
he goes he goes here conquer your inner
[ __ ] he said conquering her [ __ ] he
said do 30 deadlifts and I said all
right
and use a face cloth use a face cloth
doctor I'm sorry to hear that so it went
away and your it hasn't come back oh
yeah I'm great now it's gonna be chronic
I think the way that he was talking
about it that sounds cool too yeah
chronic chronic sciatica
I'm seeing it I shoot lasers out of my
eyes when really it's just like I can't
walk
but yeah that one for the last month
I've been dealing with that and I felt
58 years old
how old are you can I ask that 25. oh my
God oh my God
I'm turning 35 and there's 10 years
between us 35.
I'm I'm 37. okay
stop it you guys don't even don't
confuse me please why do you lie about
your age today actually I heard which is
they do this [ __ ] can we pull up the
Wikipedia yeah
yeah Brittany I'm not 42 I just want to
let you know that okay it's a stupid
joke 50 under 50. no you can Google my
Wikipedia my boss is 42.
Ethan Klein birthday Ethan Klein look at
this [ __ ] do the math all right
astrology sign June 24th 1985 37 okay
stop it that is 37. you guys don't
confuse it again it's okay when you do
it to me but she she that's she you're
gonna mess with her and she's gonna go
on and say to other people that he's 42.
that's that's not good you're messing
with my worldview those people people
know people that's such a funny like
hyper-specific bit
he's 42. yeah I agree it's not funny and
I don't know why they do it pretty much
in fact I think you guys stop it I laugh
yeah don't encourage them please sorry
I'm funny
um here is a picture of the doctor's
office uh where you got the sciatica
the doctor there's Brittany in the
waiting you know what I remember this
day really well actually
we were all shocked that they chose that
on the carpet yeah red carpet for a
doctor's office very unusual yeah record
for a doctor's office and also I mean
what is athleisure it's casual it's
British whatever the [ __ ] 60s Vibe I was
going for that didn't land what the [ __ ]
is holding a beer like injectable
steroids is that human growth hormones
it doesn't look like a beer looks like a
prescription bottle doctor is that
Ivermectin
what is it all right Joe okay you do you
buddy you do you can Dan actually can
human growth hormone enlarge your
nipples
of course so for then I am uh not an
expert on that but because so I I think
so because I think it just grows
everything like that that's why I asked
because everybody says they go human
growth hormone who grows everything and
I go what about my dick and they go nut
that yeah not that I said why would I
take it then your
Solitaire especially for the first six
months
yeah so I was wondering if that explains
Joe's Giants
because people say he's on human growth
hormone but look at that
yeah is he this is the man who wants you
to conquer your inner [ __ ] he looks
like a walking pepperoni yeah you could
hang from those that's actually that's
wild
those are like got a good inch long yeah
yeah you could hang a painting you can
milk those suckers they've won the Nobel
Prize
okay oh wow so do you think maybe the
but like seriously is this a human
growth hormone nipple or is that just
like well maybe he's got a maybe his and
again there's nothing wrong with it but
maybe he puts clamps on them well that
but there's no areola that's the funny
thing right there's no like so funny do
you know what I mean it's just pure the
milkable part just fat nibs fat fat skin
heavy nips maybe saying it's because
he's cold but I ain't never been that
cold he's in an ice bath yeah I've been
I've been in an ice bath too my nipples
didn't [ __ ] reach out and poke you in
the eye maybe it's an elephant could cut
glass with them nipples all right thank
you Joe Rogan we Kid Joe Rogan we love
Rogan folks don't we
yeah so anyway back to the worst tattoo
all right this to me is bad so Brandon
shobs he's a comedian people don't
people think he's unfunny I happen to be
one of those people but that's not the
point of this conversation
so he has two kids
and to honor them
he tattooed them on himself like
portraits yes oh [ __ ] he tattooed them
as zombies
on himself
their kids are his name's their tiger
and Boston and this [ __ ]
tattooed them as zombies on his body how
do you know that this story is real it's
real it's a known thing why would he do
that this is a known thing
it's like he's talked about it so hard
to believe
this is known right y'all like fact
check this yeah yeah this is legit
is his why does his daughter is that a
daughter on the left I think they're
both uh the right ones kind of cute but
that's a full-grown woman on the left
well so what I was thinking oh I think
that's a dude you think that's like a oh
or boy oh it is I see it's a hat now
yeah it's like a oh yeah it's a hat Oh I
thought that was hair too yeah so the
comment or the the thing that really
disturbs me is like God forbid God
forbid
and I don't even like to talk about this
but it is worth you know you got to
think these things through thank you God
forbid something happens to one of these
kids
that's man's gonna have a zombie
portrait of them why would you say that
but this is something he needs to think
about why would you say that though why
do you need a zombie portrait that's
like me putting like a tombstone with my
kids names on my body you're like one
day it's like what the [ __ ] one day it's
horrible okay whatever yeah so is this
worse than Ben's uh Ben Affleck's no
really no the back tattoo is so [ __ ]
iconic hear it by the way just just here
it is on his body wow yeah that is so
weird like why right next to the Venice
tattoo let's go this man he's like what
does he say about it he thinks it's fine
it's awesome dude
yeah who cares by the way Ethan I found
an example of um what HGH does to your
nipples that looks really big is that
Nick Jonas
giant nipples
oh no so James Charles is on human
growth hormone I didn't know that
that's my growth hormone baby
it's rumored
it's rumored that a black hole will form
where James Charles and Joe Rogan's
nipples touch it's like uh
we can't let it happen no something
awful will happen again
um you see the clip of him running up to
Ryan Reynolds No and Noah schnapp
what I haven't seen that this is all
over my [ __ ] for you Paige so it was
at some event Noah schnapping Ryan
Reynolds were talking to each other like
really engaged in a conversation stood
up talking to each other you see James
the camera pans following James Charles
entering the scene awkwardly
interrupting their conversation and
being like hi Hi and then awkwardly
standing there it's just like you
couldn't why would Ryan rentals give a
[ __ ] about James Charles I don't know
James Charles be like yo Ryan are you on
Snapchat yeah hi sister
I [ __ ] up do we have it I'm waiting
for it that uh it's all over I've seen
it from every angle and it's so
humiliating
oh there it is how have I not seen this
watch James Charles interrupt Noah
schnapp and Ryan Reynolds
[Music]
no don't just stand there he's like
tapped him on the elbow don't touch Noah
you're not you're not allowed keep your
hands off those pins games and that was
it he interrupted them just to say hi
I'm James wow you can tell on his face
tons of angles he's so used to a certain
reaction he thought like they were going
to be like it's James yeah
when they're both like who
I love when you're saying hallelujah for
no reason and Ryan was just like nice to
meet you kids literally okay less
pictures
I don't think he's interested in Noah
Noah's 18 now so
a little too old a little too old just
just a little but when was his birthday
oh October third so it's pretty fresh
going to the Wolves maybe they can role
play that he's still 17. okay all right
cool
um with no Noah was in what stranger
things yes stranger things stranger
things period
so Ela is this worse what do you what do
you make of this
do you want it it's just so hard to like
top the whole like I always go back to
how the Ben Affleck won it's like a full
package it's who he is how he lied about
it
the way he dresses on the day today and
then this is behind everything it's just
like doesn't add up you really cannot
beat that tattoo this guy is like a goof
he's a comedian he's a comedian quote
unquote sure so there's already like
kind of like a comedy aspect to the
tattoo probably did he do that thinking
it's so funny or did he do it let's
watch yeah that's what I'm wondering get
some audio is it like what did he lose a
bet like what happened right right right
right
bro can you imagine yo you lost the bet
now you have to put your kids dead I've
been doing your arms there's a good
tattoo of your [ __ ] kids
we're all sitting around drinking water
and he comes and goes football King huh
around all those duties were like
through this like football Royal he
shows both of them so [ __ ]
embarrassed shortly
so is he explained what's happening here
he's just he's just stopping shop right
now
my first tattoo I got my neck ribs
never going anywhere else man light
touch over here come light Touch Dance
I'm gonna hand this up
it's over to Chappelle and he can finish
up
just continuing
just for one I was like God I can't even
barely just continuing the vibe of the
show VH1 in 2006. yeah yeah you can
watch from let's just he's got a bunch
of tattoos so like
yeah that's also something he's one of
those [ __ ] that has the lion tattoo
the cloth tattoo the rose tattoo those
are the Holy Trinity of like stay away
from this dude all right so hold on I'm
just trying to get it to maximum quality
here blow it down yeah oh you can enjoy
you lower the resolution man I did all
the way all the way down a little too
sharp still it actually made it look
sharper a little smaller yeah all right
all right thanks Brendan all right well
it sounds like the zombie kids don't
still can't compete with Ben apples are
you
um are you
like besties with any of them that whole
group of like Bobby Lee Bobby Lee's my
best Bobby Lee's cool
Brandon Schwab we're not cool yeah right
playing games there's a lot of them we
don't because they're friends with Joe
Rogan and we regularly talk [ __ ] on Joe
Rogan but I gotta tell you it's kind of
a weird thing because I'm friends with
Tom it's very weird I I enjoy them but
it's this weird like cognitive
dissonance I have of like the [ __ ] they
talk about should not be funny but it's
this weird thing of like I grew up with
my dad likes that sort of humor and so
that's how we bonded but in this post
tick tock age of like you're really not
that funny if the Crux of your humor is
making fun of a minority group or making
fun of this and you like find another
stick like that's in my brain at the
same time that like historically you
know what I mean it's so weird I see all
the problematic things with all of these
men comedy
but I like Theo Von I'll tell you
something oh Theo Von I think Theo Von
gets the back he's just so I love it
he's funny some of his jokes are
problematic but I think but I think the
way he does it is so like sweet because
he's almost like he just plays like
he has this one joke that I think is
great he goes like
where's the White Privilege uh he said
something about how he was just as broke
sharing the plums with the black people
and I don't know yeah I don't know I
just I ruined that okay forgive me yeah
maybe leave the comedy The Comedians
yeah oh by the way it turns out um
should have turned out it actually this
is actually what his son looks like oh
my oh my stop it he's got sciatica oh in
that case that's really sweet oh it's
actually I have it have it on which is a
night yeah
good for him yeah I do like some of them
yeah I'm like good friends with
Christina p and uh Whitney Cummings and
it's always kind of weird because they
all hang out with the crowd that we
regularly talk [ __ ] about yeah it's this
weird dynamic too of like I think they
can be very funny but sometimes it is
pick me because they hang out with so
many men and it's just a strange Dynamic
you know it's like everybody in jail
everybody in Joe's orbit is pick me
that's very strange I hate to say it
ranged Bobby's the only one that's not
picked me yeah because I think Joe hates
him for some reason I don't know why
great yeah but great but he walks he's
big time he walked his own path yeah no
I was gonna giggle and laugh like I did
though men that walk their own path
oh that go there oh yeah they go there
right it's in Celsius oh okay they go in
their own way I mean they go away from
[ __ ]
but they go their own way okay cool good
for them they just left Fleetwood Mac
you can go
do you want to have something really
gross probably not what if it's funny
can I look at it yeah yeah yeah okay I
don't want to smell it we played Silent
Library
was it the earlier this week or last
week it was this week and so what were
you driving towards here Nathan what
okay go ahead Mumble a little yeah
so at least let me respond no it wasn't
a disc I was just a little nervous about
where this is going because there was um
that video
I'm scared of that video that's all
what are y'all doing talking about
no I'm not
much of like dudes prolapsing they they
audience
did you see that oh
[Laughter]
the whole episode was about it and then
I had hunger FF is like this
internationally recognized uh uh
performer a male performer and his
specialty is he's the king of prolapsing
yeah
it was so good it was such an amazing
episode
gotta miss it can we roll the club
actually I have it here I'll roll it
I don't know if it is
a prolapse
on it
bro I'm so desensitized at this point me
too I refuse to look at it for so long
now it's just etched in my brain yeah
and why did he rip his [ __ ] pants too
like his pants are ripped because it's a
prolapse of pleasure
that's it there he was partaking in an
activity
[Music]
Mandel what are we doing
he said that he didn't know what he was
and he thought this was a guy that just
happened to sit on something and that
something that got stuck to his butt he
said you believe that no Grogan was
finger in the butt well apparently he
actually lost like huge brand deals and
[ __ ] yeah because you can't pull your
prolapsed anus on Tick Tock and not get
demonetized because look at this at the
same time this ad was going that Howie
was in oh show me that one was it oh
stape was it Staples or Target
dude you're gonna love this look at the
same [ __ ] yeah you said it was a
wet cake he thought it was a wet snake
why can't I find that app I felt so bad
I told him that I believe him so I'm
gonna stick to that now look at this
[ __ ]
Target
and go down to Staples guys we support
uh friends of the show Howie Mandel we
support small businesses Staples yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's peeking out of the pro this is you
know what life imitates art and art
imitates life and I think that's really
beautiful so I have two questions for
you okay one one of the things we don't
start at the library is we s is that we
imported a fermented shark meat
to smell okay wait so it's shark meat
yeah really apparently fermented in
their own piss
and actually Ian was gonna have us eat
it until I read in Scandinavian
that it's supposed to be refrigerated
okay and it was literally not been in
the at room temperature for like a month
it had been in a FedEx Point yeah so
bring it out and you can decide what you
want to do I don't want to smell it I'll
actually yeah just check it out how did
you guys get shark meat though isn't
that like yeah how did you get this here
isn't that like illegal or something
uh it's uh pretty common in Iceland this
type of shark meat I guess I don't think
every shark is in danger they probably
probably I don't know what they do but
they probably Farm it sustainably I I
would imagine
okay it's just mango
just mango slices the shark pissed on it
yeah you smell it first if I open it I
think we'll all smell it if he opens it
here's the thing it won't [ __ ] go
away yeah no it's not like FICA or the
Tsum strowman it's not it doesn't linger
the same way but it lingers ice
fingers Dan it doesn't linger it doesn't
look like someone's holding it up to
your face then yeah it's not as bad as
the fika fish it doesn't like it doesn't
like fill the room instantly like the
fika fish but it's it's still pretty bad
this is my boat okay should we throw it
to the audience we should uh I want to
watch a reaction of y'all doing it can I
watch this see that yeah and then you
can decide and then I'll because I know
I'm not doing it oh well
because I just want to include you on
all everything we do you know I
appreciate you're like a member of the
crew to me your family thank you so much
and so you got to smell the the fish
fist I think that uh I'd like to be uh
somebody said I'm from Iceland and it's
so normal here I work at a preschool and
some kids have ate it here these kids
they're bringing these kids they should
bring into preschool is it delicious bro
is it like a pickled type of delicious
where it's like oh that is gross but
it's it's fermented so I guess
but again I don't know if this
is extra gnarly because it wasn't
refrigerated
because well yeah that's probably
jealous
Amy's dramatic
no he's dramatic maybe I believe that
was genuine
oh yeah see because it got me pretty
good too
it looks drier looks like it's dried out
a little bit smell it cured
come on it doesn't smell as bad
yeah it doesn't smell as bad no come on
now
it doesn't oh I smell it already
don't mess this up for me
oh that's like a penguin exhibit at the
zoo yes see the Penguins would eat this
[ __ ] up all right throw this out we
don't love her here
why did you touch it
ew why did you touch it I had to open it
I didn't touch it I just opened the lid
you're gonna pick your nose later and be
like oh my gosh I'm gonna wash my hands
right now that literally if I could
smell it already it smells like the zoo
that's a good analogy I I know what you
mean by penguin exhibit yeah
definitely but like a lot like hard like
like tons of penguins shredders are
really curious
okay so the other thing I want to show
you if you'd be okay with it okay is the
is the just by the way we we're over our
break time okay I gotta I gotta wash my
hands so okay
I'll let you think about this as I do
the copy read okay so this segment was
called the
um Clockwork Rosebud is that right
there's a combination of uh Clockwork
Orange and Howie Mandel's Rosebud yeah
okay would you watch the video it's only
like 10 seconds I mean sure
I I can't wait to see your reaction this
is a enrichment time and education
educational hour all right just pull it
up then roll roll the [ __ ] clip
yeah I still smell it you guys yeah I do
too
but it'll uh pepper your experience
yeah you got it Dan
I just sent it this is the video I was
saying I was worried that you were gonna
show and you were like I wouldn't show
that why would I do that what kind of
psycho do you think I am all right
you're not showing the screen right Ian
you're just gonna show me yeah well if I
show this at home I'd be [ __ ] banned
on all oh girl we're halfway there all
right so so so it's only a minute long
okay
yeah yeah yeah but maybe you can bail
whenever you want but it gets better
towards the end
so it says is this covet related
yeah
oh no no you did wait did you not see
the sealer no I didn't you didn't what
wait wait look look look look look wait
don't make me look at this by myself
Harry
oh that's making me [ __ ] gag [ __ ]
wait wait this is my favorite part just
look at this just look at this and I'll
let it and I'll release you look at this
look at this wait please just look at
this longer just see what they're doing
oh
oh
my God let me tell you something we
don't have to know everything and see
everything you know what I mean in the
world I have seen a lot of [ __ ] online
yeah it has been a long time since I've
had that gut Panic reaction that that
just gave me I'll be honest I saw that
for the first time this week and I ain't
never seen anything like it either it
was hard
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't think like
we human people need to see and know
everything that there is out there I
would have to agree
areas of the human race what we do is
important we put ourselves out there to
spread information and gospel and it's
our Civic nay moral duty to share two
prolapsed [ __ ] massaging each other
that we can relay that no knowledge is
power and we you know it's everything
but you know what there is a burden of
being knowledgeable I agree right I have
I now have the burden on my shoulder
this is a cross-eyed bear what was it
what Atlas we're essentially Atlas yeah
I feel it heavy right now
you're wild for doing adreads live
I'm pretty good at it I I [ __ ] it up
the thing is it's kind of become our
thing for better or worse
I'm sure the brand love that they sure
like this [ __ ] oh the sponsored today
no I don't say it like that I was just I
am not you know it's a hard segue I love
Shopify don't get me wrong sure
I'd kill for Shopify if they asked right
which I don't think they would because
they're a great Brandon right
Ethan we need you to kill someone for us
you're like you know what I do it you do
it yeah
they make
um they make it simple to sell to anyone
from anywhere whether your thing is
vintage t-shirts or recipes for ghee
start selling Shopify and join the
platform
simplifying Commerce for millions of
your favorite businesses worldwide with
Shopify you'll create an online
store in your Vibe discover new
customers and grow in the following that
keeps them coming back
Shopify has all the sales channels
sorted so your business keeps growing
they have an in-person POS system to an
all-in-one e-commerce platform even
across social media platforms like Tick
Tock Facebook and Instagram fully
integrated and they have 24-hour support
free libraries full of educational
content
that's Shopify every step of the way
baby
it's how every minute new sellers around
the world make their first sale with
Shopify and you
will too Ela I mean I would love to say
that Teddy fresh is on Shopify always
has been from the beginning and they uh
they've always made it super easy for us
and I just I cannot love a service more
than Shopify on them I'm being the most
authentic and sincere right now I really
do love their service and we've never
had any issue which is like no down time
ever considering that we're online
personalities you know how people like
to find any kind of way to mess with you
we've never had any issue they have the
best service my favorite thing is how
you're able to scale with Shopify yeah
when we started our business was small
it was just me and Ila and we didn't
really know anything and now we've been
able to scale it into you know basically
the [ __ ] Behemoth that it is today no
I'm kidding but we went from like two
employees me and Ila to like you know 40
employees and handling way more
complicated stuff with all these
different processes that you can do
anything on this thing it is really the
best service so if you're looking to
start a small business
do it with Shopify everyone any if
anybody ever asked me I always tell them
go with Shopify yeah you're you still
will not regret it yeah and actually
they've got a great offer sign up for a
free trial at shopify.com after dark all
in lowercase go to shopify.com after
dark to start selling online today
shopify.com
after dark thank you Shopify we love you
anyway back to the prolapses I'm still
thinking about it yeah you got that 10
Mile stair or whatever
Robin against you actually this is this
is kind of how I feel right now I don't
know about you
Atlas
with the world on his shoulders I
actually I need to wash my hands
oh my God you know what I posted a a
video after the video came out they have
a middle video yeah it was like on Loop
in the back of my head of like it's just
covered related and what can we do about
it I would just make Tick Tock saying
that and they started [ __ ] Broski
Nation started tagging Howie Mandel in
the videos and then he dueted it twice
oh he did and he would he would just
shake his head and be like
you posted it
about it damn I have not seen the
crossover of you guys yeah we collabed
not in a way that you could have ever
wanted I just found one of them that's
pretty good yeah he sent him a chat
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's so
I love that like brother you did it yeah
you posted that not my problem it's so
good at Tick Tock when you think about
it he he has a grasp on Tick Tock that
not many do well I can't say that also
the fact that that video lived online
for so long is wild
did you were you one of the people that
got to witness it on your feed I watched
a repost of it okay yeah I didn't see it
from the horse's mouth but I saw it as a
repost then I was like Jesus God in
heaven and then all of the remnants of
it are taken down now yeah and I don't
know honestly where it lives now because
you can't see it on YouTube it lives
here it lives here in our hearts it
lives on that monitor
[Laughter]
lives on our hearts yeah Ethan makes
sure to show it to everybody Jesus
Christ
honestly at that point that video is
like comforting that'll be there you
touch it
you want to smell my fingers it's not as
bad
no no no no no no no no no
because I I have a very like um shaky
relationship with eating fish I'm not
like I don't love it but I sometimes try
to do it because it's healthy and I
sometimes like it true I feel the same I
can't like risk my whole relationship by
smelling this and yes then never it'll
sing you over the edge yeah oh did you
guys watch this this like what the [ __ ]
Howie hmm yeah we just watched it oh
okay because that's my video yeah I know
yeah oh you know about it I've never
seen that okay moving on obviously we
got a lot of ground to cover
um it's so [ __ ] funny you had him on
here it was amazing so ridiculous he
came on thinking like can we not talk
about the prolapse no and we're like our
whole episode
oh I tricked him into thinking we was
going to be doing a America's Got Talent
like judging contest and so he said okay
we want to put your judges and so our
first contestant called in Via Zoom it
was Hunger FF
M
show Howie your hidden talent and he
drops his pants and he was like it was
like just like right now just do it
again give me the you the time stamp
okay
and how he didn't look away I mean he
got up he tried to run but he no no
those eyes stay glued to the screen
let's see
um we actually we saw each other you
know what um
do you do your own makeup I do it's
really beautiful and um also people in
the chat were saying it and I
you guys always curious too thank you so
much every time I want to show you this
okay play it
we got them all in the mood this is I
was so happy because I knew it was all
coming
this is like
it really is all right like a pro this
was the culmination of lots of effort
yeah okay bringing this all together
okay wow
you're upside down is that not part of
it yay
after all that
you want me too it doesn't matter does
he look like is he prefer me to address
you hunger yeah yeah okay Ryan or Ryan
so either hunger FF or Ryan so um
[Laughter]
he's the king I'm just being serious
he's internationally explained
he's here before
and then we can kind of talk through it
is that okay
yeah
um just go ahead and do it right now
yeah just go ahead
oh my God oh my God
oh no
oh yeah
you can't even lose it I made sure I had
some hands to it I was about to have a
heart attack
it's actually yeah we got out of a scene
you're such a good sport he's so super
good I love how it really is wow oh okay
so here's the thing let's we have a game
prepared for you and it has nothing to
do with prolapses
yeah I know we've been talking about
prolapses for so long it's not all year
at this point no I'll talk about a
rectum a sphincter any time of the day I
just did you see what I put up my story
earlier today no
I'll pull it up
it's just a meme that someone put up and
it says uh
my ass hair is twisting together forming
the perfect wall against the four pound
turd leaves
I feel like that's happened to me
dude your explore page ruled
[Laughter]
forming the perfect wall against
it
yo where's knife
oh
is that that must be independent
I love those oh my God
yeah that made me uh that made me cackle
last night that's doing good all right
so we have planned a game for you the
Britney brawl all right okay we know
that you stand lots of people
and so we have decided it's time to make
a stand that's good oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
this is my March Madness so each each
round
they're gonna go head to head
until we have a grand champion who is
responsible for this who's the who's the
Broski Nation member on the team we all
put this together this is real effort
yeah oh God we all work in collaboration
this
week so well I thought this would be so
much fun and I'm so excited so we're
gonna go order we have the pictures here
so everyone at home can see oh my God
this list looks pretty comprehensive we
threw in a couple of curve balls for you
there okay okay yeah so you know what
are you feeling good about this I'm
feeling great do you watch House of the
Dragon yeah yeah Game of Thrones
I cannot wait for the second season
cannot wait I thought it was unfair then
we have to wait so long it's not even
two [ __ ] years or something yeah a
few years you know what I mean I loved
it it was it was so good and it made up
I think for the lack of uh uh effort in
the last season Yeah
well yeah I was rushed it was done
poorly it was a [ __ ] ending it was very
dumb and I I don't appreciate that you
know like one of the greatest TV shows
to ever do it of all time two idiots
yeah very very upsetting so this I think
made up for a little bit yeah I think I
really enjoyed it yeah I really love the
actors
the guy who played Doctor Who uh Matt
Smith oh yeah he's game so good
fantastic and yeah he is sexy as well
even though he's ugly so you're obsessed
with him he pulls it off I gotta be
honest this guy his look I find very odd
yeah you're not getting it it's it is
odd but like there's something about it
okay see I I don't find him attractive
but like like as a bad character that's
a bad guy yeah yeah he looks so [ __ ]
crazy yeah in fact is it the actor you
like or the character both well you
don't know that much about him I don't
know anything about him his name's Ewan
Mitchell and there is zero online about
him oh really try to look him up really
how did they do that they just find like
a completely unknown actor well he had
done stuff he's British and he had done
stuff for like BBC and some like ITV or
something like that where it's all like
period piece dramas he looks like he
fought in World War One you know what I
mean he's got that look about him an
old-timey face yeah he looks like he got
gangrene in World well he looks fine
here I feel like I really like him in
his like bad character look right he's
so crazy that's a lot more like yeah you
know what I'm picking him Chris Evans I
love you but Chris Evans Chris Evans
couldn't handle all this
no you need a real bad he's a goody
two-shoe he's Captain America he is
sorry Chris you need someone that will
[ __ ] in your [ __ ] in the words of Gabe to
[ __ ] you come [ __ ] yeah baby [ __ ] yeah
oh
okay first round goes to uh amen the
psycho Targaryen and this next one is
status stop uh sorry Chris I expect you
to make it further but l l
risk I don't know who the [ __ ] these
people are just be real this is [ __ ]
up who already made this did you make
this Olivia did I put Maddie healy's uh
name on the list
you're sick in the [ __ ] head
is Maddie Healy from The 1975 and Hozier
who sings Take Me To Church take me
to sings once I worship a dog he's just
the Take Me to Church no he's got a full
discography but you wouldn't know so
take me a church guy and then this guy's
another musician yeah he sings well he's
from The 1975 he sings Chocolate
Chocolate Rain that one God what an era
you come down
I've got to tell here's the deal I've
got a tattoo for Maddie Healy and that's
[ __ ] up which one is that on the left
it's okay but I think uh he would piss
me off
like realistically speaking so we'll go
with Hozier
you see you think in real life he's kind
of he'd be annoying I think in real life
um yeah I couldn't stand him and this
guy's giving you better Vibes yeah do
you like the long hair is that a Vibe
for you so far you picked the two
long-haired King I did you know what
maybe it is
no we're going Hosier you pick the
room but don't I love him so much
not anymore this is so [ __ ] up okay
yeah well you know like I said there's
some curve balls okay yeah so so bad
bunny we're getting ahead of ourselves
though or Zendaya
who in a fist fight would win Bad Bunny
would destroy her you think Zendaya's
like
what no isn't it feminine rage wait hold
on is Bad Bunny short no he's like what
I don't think so six foot and I feel
like Zendaya's powerful bro
I was gonna say she weighs 102. still
suit okay he's five eleven she's 510. do
you know what's funny I feel like I
don't know what Bad Bunny looks like
that's like that but like in every
picture he looks so he doesn't by the
way yeah okay hold on wait is his name
oh his name is Benito I typed a bad
buddy and I just got a bunch of like
questionable Bad Bunny I feel like
you're could if we he ever did like a
tell-all H3 I would just want to scroll
through your search history that's good
oh it's crazy you know I got homies who
will race that look at this who's this
that's baby okay and then and then who's
this it's the difference the guy looks
totally different angle and then you've
got this hot
okay and then here you got like he looks
like Ali G here I didn't see that
and no hate he just looks so different
he looks gorgina okay we love Dead Bunny
name one Bad Bunny song
uh the one about the
loving look at this one let's change the
topic
who's that young Benito no I know one of
the songs that's bald headed Benito but
like how's that the same dude
God he's so he's so good
I know he's popular selling out stadiums
with like a 100
000 people effect wow a period Mi Porta
Bonito
period I like his Vibe though I do want
to say yeah actually he did something
really cool he put out like uh a PR
thing to [ __ ] on the Paul Brothers for
moving to Puerto Rico and like did he
win and Logan Paul got a butt hurt and
like called out Bad Bunny I remember
seeing something about it I totally
forgot about that yeah he he was like
[ __ ] Bad Bunny he he's a tax scammer too
this is a tough one I gotta say because
[Music]
um
I love her fashion yeah and obviously
her acting too but you know what it's
got to be bad bunny I knew that that was
easy
Zendaya loving you yeah Alex and die
though she's she's the moment yeah
I'm sorry I love all of her looks She's
like she serves yeah
but she dies
you know what so here's one that's a
little
bit me up wow
[Music]
we all know you love Harry and who
doesn't right right he's a Class Act
yeah right talented creative right and
just by all accounts a really sweet guy
but what has he done for civil rights
and so then on the other hand you've got
Martin Luther King Jr yes who
needs I mean without him where are we
where would we be you make a solid point
so you have to choose between and they
both could have rocked uh a dress right
MLK could have rocked the dress
I mean you know what I have to say yeah
we'll say it you have to say it I'm okay
really put them up there
wait you're gonna oh I think they all
thought you were gonna say hairy serious
who the [ __ ] this is y'all trying to get
me you literally is in trouble you
literally are killing Harry so what what
is this follow your heart and by the way
skipping this round after he wasn't even
in your top five most places
can you believe what no that was a thing
no I didn't I didn't know if it was
serious or a joke oh they were dead
[ __ ] serious really like so because
here's what it is I thought it was a
joke no yeah no and but it's it's this
weird thing of I try to put myself in
the mindset of a 17 year old who loves
Harry Styles more than like anyone could
ever imagine like Harry because I feel
this way like Harry's gotten me through
some of the worst times in my life he's
always been there like they wouldn't
they wouldn't have picked them okay just
saying
[Music]
yeah does this look like a fake fan to
you guys
sorry but I don't know oh by the way
you're wearing a Teddy face
[Applause]
good this photo by the way is so iconic
like what that's so silly how did this
even come about it's amazing I was just
I was just living my life dude look how
happy she is
in my [ __ ] life and there you are
candidly just you know who was there in
our [ __ ] section James Corden really
ah
did James I thought it was a little over
clue was he happy or like just pissed
off well he's kind of kind of scares me
a little bit because I don't know I feel
like how can you he has such a little
hinge or something yeah he has such a
bright and bubbly personality and I've
just heard like the worst [ __ ] about him
ever yeah y'all accounts and I'm just I
don't know what to think I don't know
what to think but he was there I think
he's being export uh I think he's being
uh extradited I think they're sent the
government's sending him back deported
yeah the queen but since the queen died
they don't know what to do with them she
hated him up right but Charles needs to
be up he's going to be the jester for
Charles
or
I think you guys should preface the
distance
follow her heart and not
unless oh this is either it's not a safe
space either way you guys are gonna
[ __ ] spin this [ __ ] on me I'd
like to Omit this round but I do want to
say in defense of you Harry Styles is
the one who says like my music is a safe
space for everyone and if you're a true
[ __ ] fan you can't be out here
accusing people of being fake fans
that's fake fan Behavior like like you
guys are [ __ ] shame on you forget
keeping this fandom it's just it's like
you all need to check your [ __ ] self
but here look at this Harry's are
Infamous for being a really toxic fan
base and I it's a really it's a really
unfortunate thing that happens and it's
because everyone wants their fan fiction
moment with him and they live in this
kind of state of delusion and like trust
me I've been there okay
okay so so then
so then okay well that's good you know
that actually is you're not a fake fan
of Emma okay yeah that's actually thank
you for circling me because you couldn't
have found me
[Laughter]
[Music]
have you have you already printed and
framed that photo of you I have it okay
you should have it do you play fortnite
by the way
yo you quit wait hold on hold on no I'm
[ __ ] I'm not even kidding this is a real
is this real yeah they had it okay
in fortnite that's what I'm saying Harry
Styles doesn't he doesn't have his own
events this is real bro I swear to [ __ ]
good for them good for them yeah this is
uh important important cultural yeah
I mean let's be let's be totally honest
love MLK
but it's it's gonna be hairy thank you
for being honest yeah and then there you
go so loving him okay yeah but uh you
know and ACLU if you are watching
what you can uh have at her
no yeah I'm glad you followed your heart
yeah
I'm gonna come attack me
no I see Zayn Malik next and I love this
yeah
[ __ ] these people
you just listen to the music and chill
the [ __ ] out he's not gonna [ __ ]
hairstyles is not gonna [ __ ] you this is
and you know what else is like you don't
think that I have like a record player
and I listen to music on that too like
Spotify when did Spotify that's what I
don't get about that Spotify I don't
listen on Spotify and I keep getting
messages like you should post your thing
and I'm like I don't no I don't listen
on there and it makes like moral
judgments based off that too I I saw
that [ __ ] on Tick Tock and not even for
a second was I like oh my God they're
mad I was like you better need to touch
grass you wish you need to go sit in the
sunlight and drink a tea fortnite uh MLK
this is real they're just doing they're
doing they're [ __ ] living it up this
is this is fantastic instead of choosing
like a fandom maybe it's like who would
you rather kiss today
sorry uh sorry civil rights but I do
love him okay I think I know who Zayn is
yeah I don't know who this is this is
Tame Impala this is the lead guy from
Tame Impala and Kevin this is Kevin
Parker is that right he sings um um it
feels like a illegal but or um
borderline come a little far or what's
the third one
all right I love that one I was on the
radio driving in today actually yeah it
was on the radio yeah so so there you go
um I know Zayn he's a cutie pie
obviously beautiful eyelashes slays uh
also from One Direction with Harry right
yes is that a factor in Europe One
Direction fan of course I'm a One
Direction fan but
I have a Tame Impala tattoo mm-hmm
Kevin tame my heart is that his name
tame Kevin Kevin you said tame tame
Impala's name of the like babe it's like
the weekend it's like it's his name's
Abel but he goes but I thought the
weekend used to be a band I thought the
weight one was spelled like weekend but
he spells it
one is fictional but that doesn't stop
me Rick Sanchez obviously and he's a
friend of ours uh Justin Rollins a
friend of ours he's watching so he will
so no pressure at all and then and then
who's Justin loves Legos yes yeah he
does how'd you know that
through the grapevine he goes I talked
to him recently and he was trying to
explain to me how busy he is sure he's
like I haven't even built a Lego set
uh in one month okay you're 42. 37. I
don't [ __ ] do that to me sorry
Another Thing Justin roilin's 42.
that's Rick that's J Balvin and that's
Rick Sanchez who's Jay valvin J Balvin
is one of the highest grossing most
streamed Latin artists of all time oh
but bad bunnies bad Bunny's number one
yeah so [ __ ] this guy idiot number two
silver loser
LJ Balvin you lost no you didn't he's
richer than any of us could ever imagine
um you know what I hate myself and it's
gonna be Rick Sanchez because there is a
level of you have to hate yourself to uh
love a character like that so much and I
listen I'll say it on here I've said it
before Rick Sanchez uh hot
whoa I've played tick tocks and listen
very very polarizing my audience that's
certainly polarizing but listen Rick and
Morty Rick and Morty Rick and Morty good
morning Rick Rick yeah
okay so Oliver tree obviously
well this is easy we were we hang out uh
we were hanging out at Austin's pre-show
what a fun night bug what a [ __ ]
incredible night that was such a
treasure to meet you guys there it was a
chance it was such a fun time hanging
out with both it was it was we went to
post D's album release party which why
the [ __ ] was I there by the way all of
us it was so awesome incredible
fantastic and amazing yeah it was so
nice not real
yeah and then I don't know if you have
you talked about what they're passing
out because I have no I haven't I can
yeah he was I don't know where he got
these but like his crew had boxes and
[ __ ] boxes gummies mushrooms shrooms
gummy shrooms and it had like it had
like um it had like nutritional info on
it like a package FDA approved and [ __ ]
like where do you buy that I have no
[ __ ] clue smart idea though but he he
literally had like hundreds he's just
passing it out I pushed out we we kind
of pushed out we didn't really well you
remember oh I'm not going to talk about
that that's not gonna come off good
and redacted redacted yeah but no yeah
dance pissed at me because I got scared
and I
because I didn't want to do it again and
then Dan got mad at me you've seen uh do
you know what the Hat man is you guys
don't know the Hat man no can you Google
search
um Benadryl hat man that's right that's
me but Dan will send it okay yo I love
Benadryl yeah there's this uh meme it's
one of my favorites of all time
sometimes I think bit yeah all right
it's a tweet look right there to the
left down third row third row fourth one
over that one
you ever get so tired you start seeing
spiders me after I take 17 Benadryl and
start seeing the Hat Man
on a safe space
a little bit sure see that that was us
at the show
you guys will let my two faves it was
like the best Vibes yeah so that's kind
of uh that's kind of a slay who is she
even
um that's Rosalia
okay more like
Lord what does she do but do you speak
Spanish could you speak Spanish oh
what's the what's the origin story yeah
I'm from Texas
uh Southern California I don't know yeah
what's your [ __ ] money
well growing up in Texas I was like it's
such a diverse like Hispanic culture
like I grew up around that and it I
slowly realized like as a kid I was like
what is this divide of you know you're
in America speak English how about you
try speaking Spanish like do you know
how [ __ ] hard it is to speak more
than one language and so throughout
Middle School I learned Spanish I was
taking like Spanish one and Spanish too
I took AP Spanish in high school and
then I minored it in college oh so
you're like a genius you're like one of
those people who's like I'm just gonna
learn a second language but it's so hard
and it's hard to keep it up so it's not
the second one
okay you picked Oliver
um is there an option to kill Oliver
we can we can just empty the bracket
yeah just get him off the screen it's
hard to listen is she winning yeah
what the [ __ ]
well Oliver's here can you tell me the
backstory I run out can you tell me the
backstory of him and Belle Delphine
I don't know
I think he was just on tour right
we did the tour and I think they just
met up to do some memes together
those videos
yeah he made out with Belle he made out
and made the closest I've got is I just
got a jar of her spit you paid for it no
she sent it oh PR
we're joking I would never uh you know
what I mean that's like come on yeah I
would it's bath water is what I really
want we got that too yeah so I couldn't
get I could bottle a fart for it
he sniffed the fart and drank the water
he's done it all yeah yeah
it's gonna be really easily
yeah Oliver actually took a bunch of
Benadryl and then she appeared out of
nowhere yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so okay
the next one
is uh me versus Ela oh see that's not
fair
because clearly you're going to offend
one of us at this right and obviously
right sorry to disappoint you but we
have more Rapport than you guys do can I
omit this round as well no you have to
choose you you're either playing the
game or you're not I'm choosing Eva
thank you
after all we've been through yeah
[Applause]
all right I knew everyone chooses that
you love her man yeah every time your
day will come we'll do this for you
who made this y'all like listen
[Laughter]
okay then we've got Doja
versus uh did you see Doja she posted
the boob pics finally that she promised
the world oh the nitpicks well she said
remember she said if you get uh this
song to number one I'll post my boobs no
she did that like a year or two ago and
then it went to number one and she's
like I was just kidding and then people
actually got legit mad like you owe us
titty picks the internet's an insane
place and so but did you see she posted
pictures of her at someone's birthday
party just like naked that was her
birthday party oh yeah her Halloween
party or something like that I thought
it was something which I was invited to
really it didn't go because I wasn't in
town could you imagine oh my God yeah
we're friends
we are the same person in different
fonts and that's really troubling and so
obviously you're going to pick her
whoever this guy is no that's Alex
Turner that's from the Arctic Monkeys
he's a little pretentious yeah for sure
I can tell but I think I think Dojo
would want me to do some some sexually
explicit things that I just I'm not
comfortable with I think she's more
she's more uh and then she'd be like you
for real you for real won't like you
won't suck me it'll be like it makes me
kind of uncomfortable she'll be like
lame you're so lame she would shame me
yeah she would have a good time with
Gabe White Club I could get really weird
she'd batter him around a bit
period what get on my [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
that's wild you do it what's the back
story there oh what club Gabe he's a
tick tocker that we thought yeah I know
who but how did y'all like get connected
oh well we loved him and he called into
the show Once like a year plus ago and
his whole thing was it's Friday baby
it's Friday yeah you used watch the dues
where they would count how many times he
said [ __ ] baby and hell yeah and so um
we said listen it's Friday let's climb
them calling every Friday yeah and he
calls in every Friday so he's a friend
of the show how long has it been going
for now like
honestly I think it's
been like two years why a year and a
half yes were we doing it when we were
before we even got into the studio
I remember yeah no no we started doing
it when we were still I can't even
remember the house in the basement
she gave himself
so like okay so like a year and seven or
eight months we've been wow game every
Friday we've been calling every Friday
friends with his family now
mom went to his birthday party cute okay
like strippers and he was getting all up
yeah it was okay
Doja cat was there yeah
Joe Rogan's nipples were out big thing
I'm gonna pick dojo
I like Belgium by the way yeah I love
her
yeah okay and then I think it skips up
to the top now so if you go down a bit
so this is uh Jake and Josh kiska from
Greta Van Fleet and this is you like
Retta I I don't know I don't not super
familiar with the music but I hear a lot
of people talking [ __ ]
well like why I don't know they just
think they're corny I guess well there
is a striking similarity to like I want
to be Zeppelin Zach do you have a
problem with them I just think the
vocalist tries just a little too hard to
be Robert Plant like I'd like to see
them do their own here's what I would
say I would like to see you sing like
Robert Plant
gladly oh my gosh
I can't sing like plant but I can play
guitar like Paige so so
can we cut to the music segment the
Musical cast it's you
um this is I love both of them so much
and I do have a great event Fleet tattoo
as well oh my God but I um I've got to
go with with
my kindred soul my Kindred yeah
he's such a sweetheart and you know what
I said this last time and I'll say it
again give me a chance posting to be for
besties because he's got his baby mama
that ship has sailed
you'll settle for best I'll settle for
best friend zone yeah you can friends on
me that's fine okay I'll I'll see what I
can I'm wearing my moose knuckle Merch
this is his line with moose knuckle yeah
we were talking this there's a brand
called Moose Knuckles which is when you
wear super tight pants and your nuts
show and your balls go on either side of
the seam they literally were like let's
name this [ __ ] moose knuckles moose
knuckle and it's like an outdoor redneck
thing you ever been in a situation where
you're nuts get squeezed too hard and
see the outline you ever get out in
nature and let your moose knuckle hang
loose well that's free that's nothing
like a nice winter moaning a moose
knuckle Mountain show you homies how big
moose knuckle mountains prolapse nuts
[Laughter]
a blow job out here in moose knuckle
we're very masculine so much so we like
to look at each other's nuts yeah twig
and berries just us some mountain people
with our chicken berries and our nuts in
the snow yes ma'am we like to crack open
an egg
and bust out our Nook
every morning on moose knuckle Mountain
you're listening to Moose Knuckle radio
down coming on down here a little bit
we'll be uh visiting camel toe camp that
Camel Toe Kathy coming in later she got
some big old lips man
I told them Coleman's hair match me up
the king the moose knuckle Mountain
the queen of
big [ __ ] camel toe Camp bring your
family out yeah
come on man all right Stephen Hawking
obviously modern day genius
also he's in a wheelchair
so why did you say that what does that
have to do with anything it's important
context for the decision you're going to
be forced to make
he literally is in a [ __ ] wheelchair
well dude he's dead he's dead he's dead
he did die yeah and then of course and
then Batman handsome man
did you watch his Batman I did what'd
you think
so I liked him as Batman I thought the
movie was pretty good
I didn't love it I thought the plot
could have been better like I liked the
potential was there right I felt like
they dropped the ball a little bit it
was really long yeah which you know 15
seconds and I'm out like that's my
attention span pretty much
um but I did I liked his interpretation
of Batman this is
emo I liked it I would watch another one
yeah I would too for sure yeah uh
obviously gotta go with our pets okay
but like what about like we he we know
so much about black holes talking
radiation talking radiation yeah and I
mean he's in a [ __ ] wheelchair bro he
would just send me into an existential
spiral I mean think about me and Steven
if you will Steve on a date yeah and I'm
just like you know yeah I'm a biggest
fear is death and he's like actually
death is imminent and infinite and we're
all in a black hole and I'll just be
like this is the worst day of my life
let me get this straight you're taking
Stephen Hawking to a steep hill and just
letting him go foreign
I'm putting you in some moose knuckle
and letting them go I would never do
that yeah I get it though I get it I
would do that to Robert Pattinson though
yeah he's no Edward Cullen basically are
you a Twilight fan of course I'm a try
hard I don't even know what they're
[ __ ] called baby loves Twilight I've
never seen any of them are you Team
Edward or Team Jacob Team Edward yes
some people are Team Jacob because
Edward is so [ __ ] toxic okay they
need to re-watch I've watched her
recently and Team Jacob is very
problematic I grew up Jacob I grew up
Team Jacob Edward now I feel they're
both a really toxic unfortunate
situation I would I would I would
actually agree with you there I think
maybe Bella could find something better
yeah someone like her dad maybe someone
like her dad but not her dad I want her
dad I like that for you I thank you so
much Charlie would be great this seems
like a really like pressing conversation
like there's nothing more pressing in
our world today than yeah Team Edward
Team Jacob thank you for saying that
someone's gonna just say what everyone's
saying thank you for agreeing all right
so we got lizzo and uh Beyonce did you
just watch lizzo's acceptance speech at
the People's Choice Awards I saw a bit
of it she is such a [ __ ] icon [ __ ]
who is doing it like lizzo big dude I've
seen her play the flute I was like what
the [ __ ] she is incredible she's a flute
player she's a foot talking she is so
well spoken like but that the way oh my
God the way that moves like crazy she
can dance full choreo she's wearing
[ __ ] mugler on her tour I love lizzo
but you know what I'm beehived until I
die so this is like [ __ ] you [ __ ] see
the story about how all the conservative
freaks were getting mad at lizzo for
playing the flute I don't give a [ __ ] it
was just funny we covered it what's what
is can we bring about a flute they
literally were like they're like making
fun of her weight basically they're like
no what's she talking about an
overweight yeah scantily Cloud woman
playing it was like James Madison's
flute who he never [ __ ] played
they're desecrating they're desecrating
history girl [ __ ] history
right true you know what this is tough
because I am I have a Beyonce tattoo oh
my God oh my God I'm working on my
sleeve
any plans for a lizzo Maybe
Muse okay is this music-wise you just
gotta pick one I don't know I think it's
everything right it could be personality
why everything fashion you just pick one
dude I am beehived to my core I have to
pick sorry lizzo but I do love lizzo
that's a problem that's gonna be
problematic for you the lizzo nation's
gonna come after me you're not gonna be
happy about that one but I think no but
nobody's gonna [ __ ] you for Pick and B
we doing so the next one is obviously
what do you mean
no problem I don't know what you mean
this is Anne Frank of the Diary Fame
two hearts
two heart throws that's the haga Nagila
which she didn't never got to dance
how old was she when she oh I think just
like 14. yeah she only she didn't get to
do more than 14 others
you have to hold on can you explain your
rationale
we're trying to get the girls to [ __ ]
bury me alive like they're gonna be so
angry this is even on love about Hitler
oh my God
now that was Zach I had nothing to do
with that that's Kanye
I'm Israeli okay so like we're like
we're cool which one are you picking I
give you the pass to pick whoever you
truly want okay well she did yeah I can
give you a pass right let's move yeah
okay but like was her diary really that
good no I'm kidding it is really good no
her diary flaps no it's actually
incredible diary
[Laughter]
but what was your music like
a discography we haven't really
[Music]
so you're you're picking Elvis of course
and he's just this is like one movie
right one diary one movie I guess it's
fair he played the role of Vanessa
Hudgens boyfriend for a lot of years can
I be straight up with you about him yeah
find his face annoying I think that you
need to get your [ __ ] eyes checked
okay I find his face so annoying I don't
know why do you know what I mean either
or not
um uh
[Laughter]
I like him as an actor
bin Bindi dick
Cumberbatch his lips look like the kissy
Emoji it's like that's Napoleon Dynamite
dude
oh [ __ ] Dynamite
[Music]
good movie
Napoleon Dynamite was the first to do it
dude that movie was awesome it was such
a time it was such a everything at the
moment it was ahead of its time yeah it
was Chad's actually saying he looks like
love
oh my god oh that's fire I can see it
yeah yeah you can see it love
you need to get that office why why
right
now you guys understand what we're
saying it's the same person no come on
what are you talking about this is
literally him with glasses and curly
hair you know I'm right Brittany
why would you why would y'all bring this
to me look at him look at him not as
Napoleon Dynamite I mean whoa
this is all the same man you're right
some white guys just like all look the
same yeah crazy oh so there's women in
Hollywood that look the same too yeah
Jenna Marbles and Julian used to do that
bit where he doesn't know who Anne
Hathaway is he looks like every other
white woman in Hollywood yeah I don't
know what bit you're talking about but
I've always struggled to remember what
she looks like yeah I can never think
what Anne Hathaway looks like it was he
always messed up Anne Hathaway Sandra
Bullock yeah
they do they do and he [ __ ] it up every
time I kiss them I miss them oh okay
yeah now they pull it up but yeah I
really
they all have it's the same face just a
little different oh yeah you know when
Hassan got banned on um
twitch for Saint cracker we had a
special and we had played the cracker
look-alike
and it was actually there were some that
were really hard they're hard they get
hard
ly when it gets to like attractive white
men or it's like Henry Cavill and the
guy that looks like him and then the
other guys
all the same guy so do you think that
and consideration of him looking like
Napoleon Dynamite that you might want to
consider Anne Frank or not I think I
would like to move on
are you picking him I'm picking Austin
Butler as Elvis all right rest in peace
and Frank gone but never forgotten
best diary in the game
holy [ __ ] all right this one's a little
easier yeah this one's easy break verse
call me from we love him the Mandalorian
the Mandalorian he was great in Game of
Thrones fantastic Love Game of Thrones
[Laughter]
21 can you do some for me
did you do a whole reaction to all those
videos on tick tock what people who are
acting like they never heard music for
the first time or no people acting like
Drake is uh is uh like bouncing his his
uh ass on 21. oh what why is your feet
those are great look up uh uh 21 can you
do something for him yeah Rich Flex on
tick tock
was showing him all these memes live it
was hilarious is it copyright music
though yeah it's copyright music though
yo so these are two different people
this is what I'm saying that's crazy
some of these are insane yeah
but then when you see like I know the
difference this is like uh you know what
though uh uh the girl that Ryan
Kavanaugh is obsessed with not really
Portman and in Star Wars they doubled as
each other
this is not the same guy it is okay no
this was a game so
yeah
so wait do this one
that's Amy Adams on the right someone
different two different people
is that crazy wow yeah
who's on the left
that's I love Fisher's her name what
she's married to Sasha Baron Cohen
that's her on the left yes yeah yeah
and then a [ __ ] that's crazy yeah
I know those are two different people
yeah okay yeah yeah good you're passing
I don't know who either people are but
those are but
those are both Leo Michelle okay yeah
you got it you got it
oh wow
is that Seth Rogen excuse me
you just failed the cracker test
what's his [ __ ] name stop Joseph
let's go and love it and who's on yeah
does it not you're right no there's the
resemblance let's do that that's tea
damn it looks so much alike though yeah
they got that squinty eye swag I love
that squinty eye who's your have y'all
had the conversation of
of like being married
the Liberty should I get a pass yeah
yeah who would you oh we don't do that
again do you have celebrity crushes
I mean it's not that we just watch
Housewives all day and those women I
don't want to [ __ ] any of them they're
all so crazy
[Laughter]
no but I don't think I get a pass
I think I pass on life if that happens
yeah
those are both Chelsea Handler okay what
about this one nope Javier wait no
you're wrong that was wrong that's not
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
Elizabeth
oh [ __ ] you're right and Pitch Perfect
two different people wait Sam you must
be dying because you don't know she Sam
has like crazy space like we were
playing this game you can throw like any
celebrity and she has no idea who they
are really but you know she knows every
character and Bachelor Nation oh girl
this is true this is true actually we
can test her it's really fun it's really
interesting but do you know who any of
these people are Sam this must be a
horrible game for you
these two oh
uh the chat well they weren't on The
Bachelor I can tell you that oh people
are saying this is marked by stop it you
guys are gross you guys are crazy did
you not see that call
not really but I got a hand of what
she's a she's a show because I didn't
yet listen to she left a message about
how she did her first Mork pie she's a
performer right and she she's very
popular she's donated and she said I did
my first shoot with brothers and I got
chlamydia and so we had her calling to
talk about it it was funny what
gonorrhea gonorrhea excuse me I find I
see those let's keep the story straight
yeah yeah gonorrhea
so that was that was it so I everybody
said they're saying that's his pass it's
not my past I have no past okay
that isn't who you would pick but
everyone picked for you I'm not picking
a pass I'm keeping it straight for for
someone with no passes you sure have
kissed a lot of people this year
I'm not [ __ ] any dudes true yeah but
I have kissed three dudes right yeah and
if you include Dan
we almost made out over spaghetti
okay so who are these people a Javier
Bardem on the right and who's he then
couldn't tell you so wait secret wait to
me these look like the same
[ __ ] yeah it's not are you sure
they have different eyebrows right no
they're an eyebrows not that different
different nose right
who is it it's uh Jeffrey Dean Morgan
he's uh these are different people yes
yeah yes
that's some crap wait these guys are
like Hispanic though aren't they yeah so
this is really not even a cracker Pat
well they're white they're passing away
right the other way sorry guys
you're white cracker tell everyone you
know
okay that's crazy
I she was just in Top Gun that's Julian
no what's her name nope there's no joke
I have no idea who's who so this is uh
uh this is uh
Julie you don't know no no no this is uh
I can't think
you got the right first letter
Jennifer Jennifer
Connelly yes
[Music]
dude this one's funny oh
yeah I'm sure armchair Dax
Shepard and that guy Gary [ __ ]
scrubs it's a scary ass smile okay but
they look Brown they literally look
identical they're like the same [ __ ]
face
it's crazy
yeah and then can you do you know can
you tell if these are different people
huh
same person yeah it's the touch yeah
everybody here man
okay okay wait I'm trying to see I'm
trying to find like a really crazy one
this one's crazy this this one's crazy I
feel like there's like a whole group of
women that look like this Katy Perry is
always a Chanel yeah
throw me a curve ball guys what the [ __ ]
that's funny
no we all know this guys that's Malfoy
and then who yeah
he went all right [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ] cracked me up I know they're
different but David Spade you want to
know something crazy Keith Urban that's
a hair piece why would you rare piece
that
he has had the same hair piece for the
last what 15 20 years is that gossip
what is that tea and how do you know
that I have my sources
but that's a nice looking hair piece it
is and also if it's a hairpiece why
would you pick those highlights in Lola
that's what I'm saying you can do
anything you want up there you can have
a full like Elvis [ __ ] like elephant
trunk thing like you pick that that's
insane I'd say for David Spade I'm not
loving what he's doing here either David
Spade looks like Jamie Lee Curtis
oh can you tell the difference that's
the penguin
Batman
this is Harvey Weinstein and then this
is also Harvey Weinstein really yeah
yeah no I think wait I think that's uh
what's his name Ryan Kavanaugh no no
those are both Harvey oh no they're both
they're both right no Ryan's on the
right
yeah this no no this is Harvey oh maybe
oh maybe that is right so this is Ryan
Kavanaugh I hate that hate this not 100
but I think so crazy all right back to
uh back to the matters yeah so can you
tell who's who
twin
I'm picking Pedro every time oh okay
he's gonna make it to the very
forefronto she's one of my favorites do
you think it's great it's Drake Drake
do you think Drake's overrated
thanks right
that's not what I asked
well what does overrated mean immensely
successful always talked about
well I guess maybe he's gets too much CR
I don't know I think a little bit I
don't think he's overrated maybe just a
little I think he's just one of the most
famous people of all time yeah he's yeah
who's the black and white lady that's
probably someone you should pick who is
that or my baby daddy yeah oh Helen
Keller I [ __ ] hate her
she's like so annoying would you think
specifically you think she's a faker
well she's a phone yeah right do you
think she's a phony phony ass do you
think she's doing it for attention she
has no eyesight or hearing oh shut up
liar
okay and then all of a sudden she got
opinions about [ __ ] okay like she's
writing books and having opinions about
[ __ ] it's like shut up you can't hear or
see you expect me to believe that
technical difficulties everybody think
about that yeah were you cool here she's
a liar dude anyway
apparently she has like super
problematic opinions about [ __ ] really
right how are you gonna she was kind of
into Eugenics uh which uh yeah that's
what I'm saying how do you go from oh I
can't see you here the genics that it it
didn't have the stigma at the time was
she in favor of of Eugene and King
herself uh I don't believe so no
well that's a little bit of inconsistent
I know I I don't believe so
long do we know what he looks like I do
how do you know because he's my friend
oh really and he's gone very extremely
okay over the top play on this
Christ versus
yeah like I said we're just gonna keep
it on your toes here so you have uh
Jesus Christ the Savior yeah Jesus Jesus
Jesus of Nazareth versus he was uh God's
one and only son sent to Earth for all
of our sins yes slain by the wicked Jews
only to rise through this joke I don't
believe that I disavowed that it was the
Romans I'm Jewish also if you don't
believe in Jesus Christ you are wrong
that's debatable there's a point yes so
you have Jesus Christ savior of man one
son and then you have uh Jack Harlow
of Louisville Kentucky the guy who's
saying uh
that Fergie song yeah
he is so cute and so cute yeah no he's
awesome but uh I'm friends oh no your
dog oh yeah
he wanted to come up so bad he smells
like fermented shark no he does him five
boogers
smells like
burgers
[Music]
[Laughter]
you smell like the penguin exhibit
yeah so you're you're I just know what
you're doing you're okay you're delaying
here's here's the real situation
they look a little similar right true
true
I love Jack Harlow so much
um and I am famously an ex-christian so
you know I left the face I left the
faith did you grow up religious of
course Southern Baptist and so was there
a was there a moment where you realized
you were ready to leave the faith yeah I
was it was very gradual I mean like I
was baptized at the age of 12. it's like
you're in no I it's about right on time
I mean if you grow up in the churches
around Middle School they start doing
baptisms because it's like you're
sentient for the first time okay and I
just that is so young and I have I still
to this day struggle with like my idea
of femininity and my Womanhood and
sexuality and being sex positive because
of the church you know I will never it
is truly religious trauma and uh the
internet's helped but the internet is
also the pendulum has swung so much the
other way of like you need to be body
positive sex positive man positive no
you don't actually you need to get I
need to see those moose knuckles you can
see these like bulging moose knuckles
but I just you know hypersexualizing
yourself isn't the solution to having a
suppressed sexual
you know uh desires so you grew up in
Texas I grew up all over my here's the
backstory my Dad's military yeah so I've
lived all over the southeastern United
States even in South Korea for a bit and
then we moved to Texas about seventh
grade and then I grew up from there and
so at what point did you start to doubt
that Jesus Christ was your lord and
savior and your one true love the Jesus
of Nazareth uh is not Jack Harlow's twin
probably uh mid high school and then I
got to college and I was kind of on my
own and then I went through this like I
need to be saved again and then I was
like no I don't I'm just like I'm really
scared a little bit I got scared well
because that's the whole thing it's
Hellfire and brimstone yeah you know
fear it's all fear-mongering that's all
that I mean having an Evangelical Faith
that's all it is so amen amen for real
was it a big deal with your family oh it
still is it still is oh really I talk
about it online and my parents and
family do not like it wow and they think
you're going to hell well they think the
LA's changed me and that's really not
the case I've never been more myself
it's just that I finally feel free
enough right to you know speak about it
and it's upsetting you know because
that's a it's so much ingrained in the
culture of being Southern and being you
know having that southern family that
you prayed for every meal and you do
this and you go to church and whatever
and it's just like I don't subscribe to
that anymore
really tough for them so wow I don't
know it's an ongoing thing but I'm
happiest I've ever been so when you go
back and visit your family do you still
lock hands and say prayers and stuff you
just I play along just the vibe yeah
well because I'm not going to be like
I'm not doing that you know it's like
it's not gonna be an annoying [ __ ] yeah
and do you miss God's presence in a way
at all I missed the uh what's that
called
the like innocence of being stupid right
yeah totally because it's like there's
an answer right it's like you had I had
for the longest time a clear answer when
there was a problem I would pray and now
it's just like well
well [ __ ] Ely used to be religious yeah
I [ __ ] ruined her saved me
yeah I grew up also in in a small town
in Israel Israel is already small but
um you know a small town in Israel where
everybody is very much like you're
describing it's very um there's a
certain expectation and it's taboo if
you don't subscribe so totally taboo and
you can't be yourself and the only place
where I felt like I could be myself is
Tel Aviv so I always went there to shop
or even to work like working in a
restaurant I went I went to Tel Aviv to
work there yeah
um because I just wanted to be around
people that felt more like what I wanted
to feel yeah like but it's like you
always feel judged always and no matter
what you do it's like if you're a little
bit out there you're like a weirdo you
know well and that's also being a child
of the internet as well you know like
being I was going to church on Sunday
and then I was on Tumblr looking at you
know black and white photos of
cigarettes and bruises on you know
whatever like the whole Tumblr aesthetic
of yeah did you see furry porn on Tumblr
oh all the time and what what did that
do to your Christian mind
um unimaginable damage yeah
like that's got to question your faith
that God what am I feeling what are
these feelings Do you have a fursona
uh we have a fursuit do you wear it
first one when the time arises I legit
have a fursuit
who made it for you we bought it
but you don't have a fursona but you
that you fall into no I haven't gotten
that deep that's a [ __ ] weight
Persona I do really is it it's a Blue
Fox
who was in the military
how's a fox serve in the military just
like he enlisted like in the fox
military yeah okay the fox military came
to his high school okay and we're like
you're 18. do you want to join the
military do you want to go to college
and I was like No And so he joined the
military yeah and uh now he's a veteran
okay and um does he get he's gay veteran
Aid no no the VA dropped him does he
have a home a PTSD
yeah yeah why do I need a depressing ass
person I'm like a homeless vet
my life I'm cool right now like that's
it's the cosplay into a different
mindset right yeah I see the value in
that yeah my uh my first one is
accepting donations through venmo and
GoFundMe that's cool
um so
do you feel more liberated though now
that you're um would you consider
yourself an atheist or agnostic no I
just could consider myself an
ex-christian I don't know what I am I'm
just I know I'm not I don't subscribe to
what the Bible teaches or the culture of
Christianity because you can still be
like a doubting Christian but you still
exist within that world I reject all of
it I think all churches are corrupt
because they're of man you know they're
not of God I think that passing down a
script through 3000 years is insane like
of course it's not accurate I just I
abandoned the whole idea and Christians
have such a Negative rep as they should
the [ __ ] Pastor in one of my
hometowns
um was just suspended because he was
caught like sexually messaging with a
woman who wasn't his wife he got
suspended just suspended he's going to
come back you know it's like this is
these are supposed to be the moral
leaders of our society in Small Town
Texas that's the one thing I can't stand
is the hypocrisy of like uh absurd
telling people how to live their lives
and then like you're [ __ ] doing that
[ __ ] but that yeah the full flaw with
Christianity is like whatever the most
[ __ ] up thing you can do whatever you
want but as long as you believe in
Christ he'll forgive you and you're
right because you're like so if you're
like a prolific pedophile child abuser
if you're like Jesus my dog you go to
heaven forever and me a Jew who never
[ __ ] kids
Straight to Hell forever like come on
explain the consistency
but that really is the you know that's
the philosophy and I just don't it's the
older I get the more I'm like holy [ __ ]
that was insane that was absurd they
made us do that you know it's like I'm
slowly unlearning all this [ __ ] and it's
wild and uh good mythical morning I'll
come on here and talk about them in the
morning every time I come on here oh
they had a similar red was so
interesting they had a recent uh
departure from the faith and they're
super oh recent and they're in their 40s
as well yeah and it's it has been
there's been such an inspiration for me
too because it's like they're from small
town America as well and they're very
Southern and you know God is such a
fixture in that culture and and
to do that and raise their kids that way
as well is really [ __ ] cool so
they're unlearning all of the harmful
[ __ ] and they're and Rhett just came out
with an album about it's like a country
album about abandoning the faith and how
hard it is and I'm just like how they're
so [ __ ] cool I love that that is
honestly they are so cool that they did
that yeah at this age yeah it's amazing
well slay welcome to the uh join us the
heathens it's good to be here it's good
to be here you'll regret leaving Jesus I
know
on your deathbed he'd be like you [ __ ]
up all you have to do is just hell
forever now with all that being said I'm
gonna pick Jack Carlo so let's uh before
with that let's go by the way Jesus
actually donated thanks for the five he
says pick me and you'll go to heaven
don't hate no no hate please
that's Jesus ladies and gentlemen Jesus
yeah okay draw Carlo L Jesus
he died for nothing idiot
just to get picked you [ __ ] died
Justice Jack Harlow picked above your
broke ass for a white rapper with
earrings to be picked over you what a
loser
serious at all
okay what's up now what yeah so okay so
now we're gonna go to the second now
we're now we're picking we can power
through now we can power through yeah so
we've got uh can we this is gonna get
harder and harder so we've got uh the
Targaryen dude versus dude
me and okay
crazy you like that bad boy I love his
character he's so Disturbed he's so
scary he's so scary so you would like
for him to be your life partner uh no I
would like to write a fan fiction about
me and him or if anyone in the chat
would like to in that evening yeah one
passionate like it's so scary toxic and
do you do you guys have sex on the
dragon or next to the Dragon no it would
be in the chambers you would know he was
there in the dragon pit right yeah right
okay moving on you got Bad Bunny versus
Harry now this this is a big mess this
is a this is a hard one
but I again running with the fan fiction
narrative it's Gotta Be Bad Bunny whoa
Gary Styles stands are Quake Harry
Styles stands just sent Anthrax to my
voice they are literally oh
[Laughter]
you gotta know Harry Styles is like I
just love that it's an open space and
it's a free space for everyone meanwhile
his fans are like
um
I hope your mom rocks
literally 16 year old Harry fans on
Twitter can you hit clap if you want
them to suffer
The Wendy Williams clip death to the
mall yeah we have all of them clap if
you think she should suffer yeah
audience ever
it's like God for capital punishment
I love that if she should suffer we'll
talk about what we're gonna do about it
clap if you've ever wanted to kill
somebody yeah
it's like um
um wow
yeah I love when they've handed the
audience and audience is like
he's the best uh Rick Sanchez all right
Rick Sanchez there it is I'm I'm this is
my fatal character flaw is I love
reading and writing fan fiction about
really awful men okay I get it because
it's the like I could fix them thing you
know oh you think you could fix
Targaryen dude I could fix aim and
Targaryen you think you can fix Rick
saying put me in a room with Rick
Sanchez I'm fixing him put me in a room
with Justin Roiland I'm beating him up I
could take Justin all right so uh Ela
versus whoever that is Ela versus
Rosalia
yeah I know I know thank you for
understanding I appreciate it yeah yeah
it's gonna be real something else
even though she's sitting right across
from you yeah I made it one bracket in
yeah better than me I am eliminated
immediately
okay
uh post Malone versus Patton
I was gonna say Patton Oswald versus
versus
what an icon by the way
most famous voice ever go ahead and put
postie up there L Patton l
Batman my ass so Napoleon Dynamite or
Beyonce
watch Elvis now I'm like actually
genuinely mad that's so [ __ ] annoying
why did I just come to terms with what
it is why did you say that
or Beyonce or Napoleon Dynamite yeah
I'll go and throw Austin Butler up there
oh really
dude don't say as a bigger fan base than
Jesus that's
the Beyonce Army has just been drafted
and they're marching on your apartment
zoom in on this actually don't it's
[ __ ] gross I have a Beyonce tattoo I
just got a new tattoo yesterday and it's
like bleeding they're demanding you
remove this I have a four tattoo because
four is Beyonce's lucky number and real
fans know that okay we're tattooed in
her ring finger with her and Jay-Z you
[ __ ] I see in the chat people are
posting your home address
so my parents
all right
Dojo versus your boy
yeah go and throw him up there all right
Dojo you just I think you need a dick to
make it to one of these
unfortunately but Jack Harlow who
defeated Jesus reminder you know Jesus
has a good dick
snuggle
[Laughter]
I bet you his comments are sweet and
nice
frosting yes she's nice damn nice Jesus
ropes dude people got ropes it's so
gross no that's actually the most like
like disgusting
they call it ropes all right
and one of the guys on that show he
swears he's not gay but he loves he's
only fans of male stars who have the
biggest [ __ ] shots and he calls them
ropes
and it's so gross Richard by the way you
know what I'm talking about okay yeah he
could even recognize the voice of them
when they're coming he's such a big fan
yeah you heard that yeah and he he's
straight
apparently yeah annual Ferrera yeah you
know what it that is one taste maker
like a taste maker and I think that's
beautiful you can be a fan of another
man's art who's got fatter rope between
Japanese
look you can show my hat here again
okay okay
this is hard [ __ ] off you got it to say
I love Orville if Orville wasn't gay
I would pick Orville but I have to pick
Jack that's fair Jack advances now we're
really getting in here we go Bad Bunny
we're in the throws first aiming
[Music]
I really like him but this is my hyper
fixation of like the last two months
like I'm still deep in this I have gone
through all of these people like if we
would have done this quiz at any other
moment in time it would have been a
different answer okay but this is it
this is everything it changes by the
hour so then we have Rick versus whoever
that is again I don't even know who I
don't know
is she an actress a musician singer
okay you hate women just say it
just [ __ ] say it whatever she's the
only woman you hate women
look at your racket
yeah going through a recession
Rick Sanchez by the way okay
is this a picture from your family you
know that is periods like that is
cuntiana
Grande you can't say that why not okay
just so you know I did it I said it you
said you said
now tell me we don't pull that back up
can you send that to me
[Music]
you look good right that's pretty dope
yeah you guys could work you guys could
work we could like demolish a village
with dragon fire and then [ __ ] on the
back of the Dragon
maybe with the uh amongst the dragon
eggs in the nest maybe use them as yeah
I don't know maybe they vibrate or
something
this is so ridiculous okay so amen next
okay where are we going next
posting Napoleon
throw them up there wow
Austin pose okay then you got get rid of
Jack Harlow get him out of there oh you
like daddies you look older men it has
to be the right ones
um
um Oscar Isaac you like Oscars very very
beautiful from Dune he was in Star Wars
he's got like oh
one that Marvel show what was it Moon
night yeah Moon Knight
very hot yeah George Clooney Robert
Downey Jr Matt Damon I love all of them
okay
um so that's the yeah you're too old
for Leo
[Laughter]
I was just saying you're too old for Leo
unfortunately I know I just I just
missed it yeah 25. well no he's dating a
25 year old
I think it was big news no because it
was big news because he dated outside of
that for them now he's dating he picked
up a new girly oh literally
I mean I'm not what's your name I want
to know who she is
watch me you know be funny we pull up a
picture and she's like she looks hella
old yeah
GG is GG 27. no [ __ ] way he's doing
Gigi's way
wait who's Gigi Hadid yeah what yeah
Bella hadid's sister
what happened wait you know about Zayn
and Gigi's Mama right yeah he like he
like beat the [ __ ] out of there holy
[ __ ] wait so they broke up and now she's
with Leo when did she finally happen
thank god dude Leo's trying to be a step
dad this is drama llama I know I love it
wild wow this is crazy I didn't know
about this well that is this confirmed
because I didn't even know yeah they've
been hanging out in New York I know all
right it's the opposite of what you said
because she looks really yeah first of
all let's just be clear
but she's a mom so that actually says a
lot about like who we dated before to
like dating a mom yeah damn okay
DiCaprio
but and her son is with uh or her child
is with Zane Zane yeah ooh you know
what's crazy yeah
yeah we'll call him out about that he
just Giggles like he knows he knows that
that's like he likes young women wait
how old is Zayn
like 20 Harry's age like 28. so
he is 29. I don't know who this is but
apparently he's 24.
00
you guys know Zane I think I must have
done it's different
he had some work done so he's 29 and
then Leo
I Don't Wanna Live Leo's 47. yo dude he
got to meet 47. the daddy of the of her
he's 29 and he's 47. how are you even
gonna like holy [ __ ] I'm sorry Leo just
had a birthday he's 48. 48.
oh dude imagine he gotta go see Zane
who's 29.
she's like I gotta go drop off my baby
like Jane has custody this weekend cause
that's like a child when you're 48. holy
[ __ ] if you guys think I'm old he's got
11 years on me but you know
what's your math you're 40 37 six years
funny guys wait so what's the math on
that yeah can we oh that's right we need
to stop with this bit since Bradley
Martin said Ethan's gonna die at 64. so
if I don't lose weight all right you're
nine years old today thank you
clap if you think he should die
I'm gonna kill somebody I never wanted
to kill somebody
oh
apparently
um I don't know this is from December
1st
yeah Leonardo DiCaprio parties on a 150
million yacht during Art Basel Miami and
it was like filled with models
and he's so nice dating GG at the time
this was seven days ago that was eight
days ago
there's no way they're going they're
dating yeah dude's on a yacht with like
yeah 100 models yeah baddies what does
she think he has Genghis Khan he's like
you know what I mean he's like he's got
like a whole Harem on a yacht yeah he
runs just goes room to room to room he's
the Madame at a brothel
damn all right so let's move it on yeah
versus Rick Sanchez it's gonna be aim
and Terry you know what damage sorry
Eamon okay and then post first Pedro
I'm seeing Gigi was at that party just
real quick that's okay you know what no
judgment I mean you know just saying
just saying I'm gonna go
um it's
Pedro as the Mandalorian could we swap
that out and put the Mandalorian helmet
this is the way yeah one second
give me 30 seconds we gotta tweak
yeah Pedro with a helmet on yeah how
handsome can he be if you want him with
the element okay it's a maybe okay now
look at the two top ones they have some
form of their face obstruction oh
interesting they're both characters
there we go
but to throw a curveball on this was it
actually Pedro in that suit I think it
was yes uh only for certain scenes
actually is a different actor we don't
need to know some dude named [ __ ]
just stunts uh some of them were him but
most of them were not right but all the
walking around and talking yet all right
so we have Pedro the Mandalorian face
fully covered versus Hungarian
uh what does it say about me maybe I
want a man that I don't have to look at
something special well let's see if who
you pick all right
for fan fiction purposes only
Commando will
[ __ ] helmet
there it is
[Applause]
wow I gotta say I didn't expect that to
be the finalist I did not this is so
unexpected I shocked myself and so what
is the fan fiction like with Pedro
you're in the Mandalorian world is that
what's happening does Cam have his uh
his Mando Teddy fresh one yeah go get
that what happened
ears on the top
um so what's the fanfic take me through
it so let me I'm gonna let you in on a
little little secret with the girls
for the mentally ill girls like me we
read fan fiction uh on a website called
AO3 Archive of Our Own okay and it is
Wattpad if you've ever heard of Wattpad
it's a fan fiction app okay and uh
you can touch it yeah let me you can
feel it no that is so [ __ ] scary
smell it oh my God has he worn this
Pedro yeah you should send this to him I
love it
my head's not big enough
look at this oh wow we love it that's
awesome that's it that's what the
mandalorian's wife girly looks like okay
so anyway
AO3 is this website where you it's fan
fiction but it's like really [ __ ]
erotic
okay super graphic it's super graphic
it's super like throbbing [ __ ] okay okay
yeah
it's hot
and so it's very much that and I was
reading that at the ripe age of 14. okay
and that is there's a famous Mandalorian
fan fiction on there called rough day
and it is some of the best literature
I've ever read and you just walk me
through the plot or should we pull it up
because I'm actually curious to know
what you're getting I'm reading yeah
this [ __ ] is um
it's some of the most graphic yeah it's
by uh it's called rough day I think it's
by no Droids on Tumblr it's on Tumblr as
well I'm in the Deep yeah thralls throws
of the internet so can I so you spent a
lot of time on this website oh yeah okay
interesting proceed top right yeah yeah
do all these disclaimers okay rough day
summary yeah who knew that agreeing to
babysit a bounty hunter's weird green
little child would be so full of
surprises oh so she's babysitting baby
Yoda he's not involved in a sex x is he
no that would be immoral go to like
chapter chapter no no go to the end of
this chapter it happens in the first
chapter period
okay wow go to like uh this is okay
[Laughter]
yeah
okay okay okay okay okay okay
let me yeah okay okay you're okay I'm
trying to find a good place to start
it's just a lot
oh my God
okay like you're not actually prepared
so who's okay wow this is this is all
super you found this stuff at 14. oh no
I found this stuff at 23. oh okay yeah I
just said that you were reading it oh
yeah I've been reading fan fiction since
I was about 13 14. really okay uh but
this is this was a pandemic find
I was bored the [ __ ] tears during the
pandemic I found Mandalorian fanfiction
I said hey
here we go all right so I'm just gonna
try to cut in here mid mid moment I like
taking care of other things too you say
softly and to the dip of his shoulder
blade ah [ __ ] stars because they
can't say God
why because it's the Star Wars Universe
there's not a god
like it
he grits his [ __ ] pulsing between his
legs
too too much relax you and her oh so
you're encouraging yeah so you're the
it's you you're taking control yeah your
first person okay relax you encourage
okay because this is because they never
take off the arm that part of the
fantasy yeah you can't see it you get
under but he leaves the helmet on he
leaves the helmet on yeah
it's like gold so clearly he's not going
down
no the lights just have to be off
but advisor up and go down does that
happen
does that happen
does he pop the visor so he can go down
no so they're in are we really doing
this they're in the whole of the
spaceship okay yeah all the lights have
to be off think about it they're in
space there's no sun there's no whatever
they're in hyper hyper speed light speed
yeah it's completely dark in the ship
let's take his helmet off and that's how
oh and because she called Darkness yeah
or not she anyone first person reader
POV you and you can't see interesting
yeah it's a it gets so [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
this is good so wait yeah it says relax
you encourage reaching your other hand
down to gently cup his ball
so is he wearing he's not wearing pants
I guess so are they talking right now
uh not yet
sorry because you just jumped in kind of
halfway through
um he was on a mission he got hurt
badly injured okay and he's bedridden
he's no no he's he's like stumbling back
into the ship whatever and he's like
about to pass out and he's like you need
to cauterize my wound like you need to
cauterize it okay and come to find out
he gets off on pain
so a little bit of a of uh
he gets off on pain
I don't know something about her
cauterizing his wound made him very
horny and then this happens yeah okay
okay so he's like bent over writhing in
pain and she's like let me grab you let
me go ah perfect time
so the tags are very interesting for
this some of them are like keep the
helmet on whoops my hand slipped in the
house daddy Mendo hours are at 24
[ __ ] seven and dirty talk
wait what are those titles those are the
tags for this story okay so she says
relax you need rest just come like this
c-u-m I'll go down on you later if you
want and then quite suddenly
so suddenly that you think it might
actually surprise him more than you it
does
the Mandalorian comes hard
in your hands right there on the floor
dark clothes bloody and prestigious
uh I guess he has prestigious armor
halfway ripped off his body do you get
it now like a ragged gasp tears through
the modulator jacket off and his back
Rings the chin of his helmet lifting off
the ground a few inches with it and his
balls pulling up deliciously tight under
your palm
this is this is wild a lead immediately
begins to coat your fingers as the
robbing throbbing ropes
yeah ropes is actually they need to
graduate the road yeah
as he clings fists against the hole
you bite down on his back and moan with
him oh
this is why
James yo listen to this
no embarrassment just so [ __ ] turned
on you might actually die period period
he tastes Divine oh [ __ ] you can't miss
that I skipped over Mormon masculine
gorgeously thick
coating the shallow Hills and shores of
your knuckles Jesus Christ that's
beautiful literature when you like let's
take a step back think about that
wording wow how beautiful
you take a look this is how it ends you
take a you take a second to look back at
him laying there and gorgeously
deceiveled pile on the floor dead asleep
it fills you with a surge of pride
being able to reduce such an Untouchable
reputable Bounty Hunter to the level of
any other man
I let her have her way
you already want him again you are
addicted to the glorious power trip of
feeling him let go and fall apart under
your touch
hell yeah right
it's a beautiful story
so if you are still Christian would you
be not allowed to read this
he's better than porn right hell
probably not well you know what this is
the whole thing this is like the
experience of being a young woman online
so many young girls learn about sex
through fan fiction really like up
through about Anatomy about like sexual
pleasure like they learn about it
through everything I bet everyone in the
chat who reads fanfiction right now is
like yeah she's right really is that a
good it's probably is that a good place
to learn about sex absolutely not is it
such a romanticized way his hot Gins
glistening in the Starlight I think the
first time you've uh you feel jizz
you're just probably like
panic attacks
not like this
wow yeah I uh probably not but I was
reading fan fiction even in the height
of my Christian because it was like did
you feel guilty about it all the time
all the time I was like this is just
everyone [ __ ]
sooner or later and then you die do you
did you manage to get rid of everyone's
saying it's true like there's tons
in the chat yeah maybe I should start
writing fanfic because it's like a good
Market you should yeah do people do like
comedy fanfic like or do you want it
serious it depends whatever you want
it's out there out there you know rule
34. yeah yeah right the same exists for
fan fiction no but I want to write
something that people are going to pick
up and read so could you do one that's
like kind of silly and funny like let's
say
Epstein's Island he's everyone thinks
he's here
fanfic are you [ __ ] serious
on this website
yeah oh it's me and Ryan's having all
the strategies wait wait go back up no
no no I want to read you didn't see the
tags
oh wait was no wait who wrote this
Slow Burn h3h3 humor romance flipped
rank Kevin Allah
it's not about the author who the
characters are yeah no I see it's
[ __ ] me and Ryan Cavanaugh
Mike have not checked his Instagram
Direct messages he had been on Instagram
for three hours so far busy buying Bots
to boost his abysmal engagement and
interacting with his commenters he was
eager to check DMS hoping it wasn't
another one of those paid H3 Bots out to
get him
in a shocking twist of fate it wasn't an
H3 bot it was Daniel Keane AKA keemstar
Ryan up in the message smiling as he saw
the content hi Ryan I have some
interesting information regarding Ethan
Klein I'd love to get on the call with
you to discuss it unbeknownst to him
this would be the beginning of a
beautiful friendship hit the next
chapter where's the come go to the next
year
there's another chapter oh no no
so many chapters wait I want to get to
the sex part keep going keep going next
chapter
oh I'm drunk keemstar was nibbling some
cheese
oh God this is getting better yeah you
know what maybe we maybe you shouldn't
read
look up more H3 once yeah I searched the
History Podcast
you just have to have an account yeah
and then and then they're rated or like
how does it work you can you find them
by the tags
um and then I'll tell you mine there's
archive there's like content warnings so
some of them are [ __ ] up oh it like
incest about famous siblings and [ __ ]
like that's all good to go that's all
fine nothing gets taken down on here
unless it's like I actually don't know
if there's censorship on AO3 I actually
don't know about that but I have a lot
of Ethan Fick I've seen some [ __ ] up
stuff on here search Ethan Klein I did
no no
there's literally
Jake Paul Logan Paul click that one love
me again Jake Paul Logan Paul I mean go
down the [ __ ] is this stop it whoa H3 H3
fan frick
Ethan and Ela had been known for many
things
do the second paragraph
the Sunday night Elisa said to finally
asked her husband what has been going on
little nothing been going on baby Ethan
said they were at the dinner table
eating vegan spaghetti because Ethan's
been on a diet
the
reason
has been asking these questions Ethan
you're lying I know something's up Ila
said something serious as she shoved her
mouth with spaghetti what makes you ask
that Ethan drinking his vegan soda what
well you've been coming home better than
usual and you're on a diet for some
reason Eva said LOL what's wrong with
wanting to lose my sexy fupa
this is your life I do not like this
yeah
guys feeling I don't feel good about my
legacy
that did someone actually put a lot of
time into this sat down and typed this
up
oh this one has idubbbz should I look up
colors at risky uh you could try it I
wouldn't uh what's a vegan soda
I'll call sodas vegan
tell you
I've had carbonated Pig blood uh [ __ ]
gross yeah this is a when I found out
that there was fan fiction being written
about me that's wild but this is the
thing it's a lot of that it's funny
right it's like someone wrote one about
me and post Malone someone wrote one
about me and Eamon Targaryen but that's
because it's my fans trying to make me
laugh like there are actual think back
to like Magcon days
actual full-blown novels being written
about like your relationship with Nash
Grier your relationship with Taylor
Caniff like this [ __ ] was real okay
listen the women in men we have
different perceptions like I don't think
a man I'm not gonna speak for all men
but I think broadly I don't think I had
one male friend who even knew this was a
thing like I didn't even [ __ ] know
this no because right but it could also
be an age thing I was definitely aware
sex fan fiction stuff um but yeah I
can't say I was saying I don't know
about this yeah I don't know about that
but the what's the watch or whatever
that's the one that I that's the OG has
been run into the ground by ads like so
this is the new new yeah all of those
movies on Netflix that are called that
are the after movies they're based on a
Harry Style squat pad
a famous Harry Styles fanfiction that
got like a hundred million reads no
there is a whole subculture of this
online that's like I have lived in this
quite literally since I was 13. oh my
gosh
yeah I didn't uh Zach did you know about
this [ __ ] or Ian I didn't even know this
was a thing nah man
oh man
[ __ ] grossed out oh man I was fully
aware yeah yeah I grew up on Tumblr so
yeah there you go okay so period yeah
putting on the growth of Ethan Klein
ones I knew about it who do you think
wrote them
um
I have one more segment for you okay and
it's gonna be fun are you ready with it
Sam wait we didn't
we didn't settle this we did it's Mando
yeah
I'm gonna go home and watch this back
and regret it though we can do an
alternative take alternative take right
yeah
okay so we notice a trend of you
following a certain Twitter account and
commenting on their posts
and it seems like you kind of seem
interested in a lot of this [ __ ] up
food
this is a cheeseburger chocolate chip
cookie box oh my gosh and it doesn't
look that bad you wouldn't need it
exactly that looks [ __ ] delicious
there was a uh oatmeal cream pie okay
cream pie I don't need that my food uh
no I love it oatmeal cream pie White
Castle I would eat this too
[Laughter]
this is a [ __ ] abomination of God I
still don't know what the [ __ ] this is
hey yeah you would eat it no
no
no well here's where
where we what we've done we prepared all
this food
[Applause]
do you think I'm joking but I can't
believe okay yeah she thinks you're
joking guys how about that last one that
you said that you would eat that
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this little sausage patty oh
that looks kind of yeah
McDonald's Patty right Sam yes wait you
put the [ __ ] pickles on it you can
take it off can we get a close-up of
that so yeah here's a oh wait I am so
excited my mouth is interesting so this
is two chocolate chip cookies and a and
a cheeseburger in the middle cheers for
real yes cheers for rolls
warm
it's not it no that's not it [ __ ] God
because I'm hungry
I'm gonna do another it doesn't make
sense to my brain maybe with just one
cookie
okay there's no cookies for you
um
it's not enough it's too much cookies to
take one off
if it had a fatter Patty maybe so let's
try this way yeah
her
6.8 out of 10.
let's do better I'm right
it's the beauty of a McGriddle is that
the the Patty
or the bread has the syrup in it so it
makes it sweet
let me try bite with the pickle
no
you don't like pickles not on a cookie
there's two it's a hamburger it's a
hamburger what's going on I don't hate
it I mean clearly I would never like
willingly eat this or make it pull up
can we do a live pull-up of that account
oh
scroll through go to tweets and replies
I'm spitting I'm eating the burger
though yeah I mean it's okay the form is
delicious
on Twitter account you linked me oh yeah
I got it thank you guys go to tweets and
replies and scroll through the replies
this man who runs this account
is one of the horniest [ __ ]
alive really yeah so he'll post these
crazy and I'm like oh my God oh is it
safe for work
it's just like titties oh yeah we can't
show titties okay well don't show the
screen then yeah just don't don't show
it to him
what the [ __ ]
I'm not logged in guys so I can't look
at it
so you just pee horny posts
he'll post oh thank you so much he'll
post a picture of like this or like
I don't know just the grossest thing
you've ever seen and then two tweets
later is some like big titty goth girl
why using the response is like just a
chance
oh my God no and everyone's like shut
the [ __ ] up and post the nasty food you
[ __ ] that probably shows up on their
feed right it shows up on my constantly
oh so you have you ever considered like
unfollowing him for that no because I
enjoy the content yeah I'll bear through
some titties I just can't open Twitter
in public now because I'm like this
[ __ ] who runs this account will
put tits on my timeline she actually
make all this stuff I don't think so
don't show in crowdsources it okay so
here oh well here let me show you guys
the original post so don't show this
oh it's age restricted I have to log in
apparently it's just an aspect it's an
ass pick and he responded you can show
this to him trying to fit the whole
thing in my mouth oh my God
that's graphic
that's pretty funny though but the porn
thing is probably hard to manage but
it's not it's like soft core porn it's
just like it's just you can open Twitter
in public exactly you can eat that
hamburger no I'm not
[Music]
you can go to my account too and scroll
through my replies because I respond to
a lot more I'll say like now this is
[ __ ] up I wouldn't need that
I equally say that I would and would not
eat them
I appreciate you guys preparing this
though this was there's one
can do we have any just
do we have any hamburgers Sam
we have one left you want that yeah
bring it bring it
fly in the Patty I love this yeah last
time we ordered a pizza
we'll make it a tradition I love that
for us
um
I need to log into Twitter on this
computer guys
otherwise they don't let you scroll
I believe that that's so dumb no
is that a new update
so I got your account here
let's see if these were Pillsbury
cookies it made all the difference
[ __ ] you guys spam shot with a Spam
flask with Gingerbread spiced rum in the
middle of the spam shot glass what
that's a good question does he make he
doesn't make these right you said [ __ ]
you guys for this one yeah that one made
my stomach which I get I co-signed that
um
all right next up oh that's a burger oh
the queen
yeah that was good man I feel like
well chocolate I was getting hungry I
was just getting hungry too that looked
good you want to bite are you hunting me
if you are you going tonight I'll eat
that whole thing go have these and we
got our second meal are you really
prepared
so this is the second one wait what the
[ __ ] is this
oh this is the oatmeal cream pie White
Castle wait how'd you get a White Castle
burger
oh [ __ ] so [ __ ] funny so then here we
have round two these are just two more
cookies yeah it's actually a very
similar dish when you think about it
yeah
so this is okay oatmeal cream pie white
that's inside
it's a just a just a White Castle is
another fast food joint okay hey I love
you guys I love you this is so fun every
time here's for real
oh that's [ __ ] up that one's way worse
that one's super weird that's awesome
I've never had White Castle
it's amazing are you sure yeah I'm gonna
try the burger patty oh it's because
it's so greasy I hate it
this is a wow the worst
that ain't it
that one's a bit like translucent
why is it glowing radiated that one is
not it good
and I tried my best man
I absolutely tried
these are fire though we found the food
you won't come yeah this is it but you
just have to dissect it and eat it
I'm giving me enough time I'll eat the
whole thing
laughs
um can you pull my Twitter up
they're logging me into a Twitter right
now we're hacking Elon
so you should have Elon on and roast him
you should have Elon Musk on and show
him the prolapse video I need him to
unban me on Twitter first damn we're not
on talking terms facts
so we are
um
did you guys make that [ __ ] up Oreo
disaster one I think they did I think
they did that one's gonna hit
it looked I don't know what happened
this one I'm down with this one you know
is gonna be good because I like Hawaiian
pizza you would be like throw some
olives on there and [ __ ] jalapenos
forget about it forget about it it looks
delicious wait do we have a bunch of
pizzas Sam
yes are you [ __ ] me in the tits right
now bro bring that [ __ ] out [ __ ] should
have got my camera [ __ ] in my
[ __ ] open eyeballs
there's a whole bunch of food you said
they're saying we should wait until the
segment's over okay that's fair keep me
hungry
or maybe bring it though at the same
time maybe definitely let me look at it
and think about it yeah let me bring it
over let me think about it
Pizza Hut oh my God what is this
wait what topping is that what is that
is that banana peppercini what the [ __ ]
Abomination Pizza is this oh it looks
like Buffalo pizza oh it's Buffalo smell
it
there's more than this when did y'all
order pizza
oh my God Is it bad
um
it's pizza so
that's delicious yeah
not gonna complain about this
that is a [ __ ] up plate of food
that's the kind of food you're better
off like going hungry
you'll be better off there is nothing
nourishing on this plate
hmm
I went to um
barbecue chicken
yes sir it's regular do you want regular
no yeah take this away
I'm a barbecue girl do you want some of
this I haven't had pizza in months
this is our tradition
oh yeah this is it okay
I was gonna say um
I forgot never mind oh I went to a
dietitian oh no
because I was like I don't know how to
feed myself and she was like period
and I was like she was like you need to
abandon this idea that there's healthy
and unhealthy food and I was like do I
because there are unhealthy Foods she's
like everything has nourishment in some
capacity and I'm looking at this place
and I'm just enabling you
know I'm looking at this plate and I'm
thinking she was smoking something yeah
oh my God what's this one
buffalo chicken okay
um this is barbecue chicken wait what
was your point though
like that I shouldn't be afraid of food
I was like I'm not afraid of it that's
the issue I eat too much of it I love it
she was like
there are no good and bad foods every
food has nourishment for you it's just
in moderation and I was like I get the
point but like if I shut down for lunch
and had this I'm feeling worse than I
did if I just didn't eat but you know
yeah
that can't be her point though
more pizza
I gotta think that he was driving to a
bigger Point than that
I'll bring up that pizza uh M M's
how are we feeling in the chat
um chat
he's loving The Vibes
are you working on anything big right
now oh my God
I am there we go thank you Sam so I've
talked about trying to stick clear it oh
no I'll eat it
I've talked about for a long time how I
want to have my own
hot ones like I want to do my own hot I
want to host a show yeah I want to host
a show that isn't [ __ ] like
so is it bad or what I didn't try it
yeah should we try it so you don't want
to do like hot ones or you want to do
like a talk show that has like a stick
like that period yeah
delicious
mmm nice texture yeah that'll that'll
that's totally fine and you're just
great it looks like fun the crunchiness
and the softness it's happening hey but
the flavor
oh yeah it hits you in there the
chocolate you should go back to that
nutritionist and be like
try to [ __ ] tell me that every food
has nutrition
what do you think about this you [ __ ]
my dog will definitely out there
it's on the table I think the orange one
yeah
yeah this would be a lot better without
M m's on it yeah
Just Pizza
anyway yeah I'm I'm uh that's in the
works because I'm doing my own show that
has its own
it's Celebrity Guess focused and we've
already booked some celebrity guests
very excited and so look for that in the
New Year how fun yeah are you working
with
like
a production company or I'm totally
self-produced okay we love that
that's the way I did it that's what we
did it yeah I don't want to be beholden
to anyone you know if there's a month
where I can't do a video I shouldn't
have to be like like that's just I don't
my opinion about working with black
networks and [ __ ] mm-hmm
don't do [ __ ] they're just a pain in the
ass they just take money yeah so
yeah it's totally we're filming it in my
spare bedroom oh wow are you building a
set and stuff that's so exciting it's
really it's gonna be slay so um
can you tell me like about the concept
are you keeping that secret I can hit a
bit yeah I'll tell you a little bit okay
you know Medieval Times
it's the theme but it's not like we're
watching jousting as I have my own like
this we completely transformed the spare
bedroom it looks so [ __ ] good it is
uh medieval themed and we have a guest
celebrity guest on
and I am auditioning them to join my
small Council I love House of the Dragon
[Music]
so uh that's it I'm asking them
questions and we share a meal and we eat
with our hands like a medieval time oh
and I make them wear a cape and I make
them like act like they're in my
Cinematic Universe okay [ __ ] blast we
already filmed the first episode oh you
did yeah
so how'd it go good it went so good can
you tell us who it was no no it won't be
surprised when does it come out
hopefully
um February fun because we want to
pre-film like three episodes and be able
to like schedule up and hopefully get
some going on a schedule well that's a
dog so cool but I want to do something
like this for a really long time because
Sean Evans is the greatest ever do it
right Amelia from chicken shop date
greatest ever do it you know like also
that guy you said from uh I forget his
name
the guy who's blowing up from Barstool
who does this celebrity yeah incredible
like these and they're all original
ideas that kind of focus on the same
thing so this is called the Oreo Burger
bukaki you think I read about this in a
fanfic yeah yeah yeah yeah my Knuckles
what do you think that white is
it's got to be the Oreo cream custing
whatever it does I hate it
the Oreo robe stretched my knuckles I
just want to say that here we go I I
love it
that's crazy right there that's [ __ ]
gross looking what did I say to this
better shut up and eat it did I say I
would eat this or did I say this is
gross you said you would eat it I think
milk
yeah someone needs to jizz on this
though no
they wouldn't want to volunteer
by the way you see what my crew thinks
about you we splitting one and you got a
whole one
all right I'm going in I don't give a
[ __ ] okay here we go
oh
very crunchy
I just want to say I love that idea for
you and I think you're gonna be so good
at it yeah thank you so much yeah for
sure it's perfect for you we'll have you
all on eventually
okay you don't have to
I I don't know if I can go in I'm like
it's tastes like Oreo the Oreo is very
overpowering
that's right
it tastes like beef jerky it does taste
like beef jerky if you think about it
long enough
the Oreos all I taste I might do another
thing
[Laughter]
oh it's not working I'm gonna get the
secret sauce not working for you yeah
you know what's good about this sandwich
if you take off the Oreos
it's a Big Mac and then you eat it like
that
and that's really good you know what
with one Oreo I'm gonna give it a thumbs
yeah because I'm a filthy [ __ ]
monster you like it
do you like it better though than just a
big man
yeah
wow
if there was one Oreo just one yeah or
if it was just Oreo cream
yes ropes of Oreos yeah yeah itches it's
actually missing some human semen I
think that would make it really [ __ ]
delicious
winning horse
[Laughter]
he's a very conservative preacher who's
obsessed with semen who tastes good
he's 100 serious
he is yeah no [ __ ] way yeah I swear
on God I'll show you can we pull him off
he's obsessed with semen but he's like
Family Values oh you found it [ __ ] I
would love to see how he merges the two
yeah maybe we'll make a little I would
argue you can't have you can't have one
and not the other
this was the worst one
that's tea because I disagree here he is
okay
the semen is is another kind of milk
putting semen in his coffee no way I
sent the full video I don't know if you
want to watch the whole thing but yeah
yeah yeah
I sent it clearly
okay I'll open it
so this is a passenger the mammary
glands and he claims that Starbucks adds
semen to their coffee to make it taste
so good I wish it is
however albeit produced by the way let's
watch the whole thing and we'll just
enjoy our food okay dinner downstairs
his dad the woman didn't realize who's
an associate the name was Jess or
something Jessica
um
that when questioned me about Starbucks
and this latte is that it's a really
it's a concoction of milk concoction uh
the Jon Stewart woman uh associate I
said yes it is a concoction of milk with
some flavoring in it yes
um and I said to her that milk is
something that's produced by the mammary
glands and it is a body fluid
produced by the mammary glands and
people tend to like its taste it tends
to nourish people it tends to give life
is probably you know it's a strange
thing that milk comes from the mammary
glands and etc etc and I said that semen
because you know what they had this
thing going back a year ago with me
talking about semen and and
they do put it in there many people
slammed me and said I should get off of
it when God wrote me told me he wasn't
going to send me any more offerings
until I stopped talking about sea bud
and Starbucks coffee I told them to keep
his offerings uh but at any rate the
cinnamon is is my fans are begging me
please stop with this image I can't do
this anymore
like you must talk about this a lot too
much calm
man said I should get off of it one guy
wrote me and told me he wasn't going to
send me any more offerings until I
stopped talking about C but Scott semen
in Starbucks coffee I told him to keep
his offerings
the Seaman is is another kind of milk
it's crazy with the Bible right on the
table
this is a man of God this is a man but
he's he's anti-homosexual he thinks he's
on to something yeah well so he his
logic made sense and then he like he's
like so breast produce milk
mammary glands milk is nutrient
nutrients it's not a mammary gland in
your [ __ ] dick then he jumps from
mammary gun he goes well women can do
that but well and then he he's like
Anyway a guy wrote me so anyway yeah you
can come from you can milk from your
dick
trying to say what is the point I think
he wants to drink semen he wants to
drink yeah okay yeah yeah it gives life
but at any rate the semen is is another
kind of milk right it's something that's
produced
by the testicle glands of a man yeah
people tend to like milk that's produced
by the mammary glands of a woman right
Starbucks has figured out
that people tend to like semen that's
produced by the testicle glands of a man
and do we have Starbucks commentary
Starbucks has not yet commented
big deal if they mix milk and semen
together it makes for some people a nice
taste now I don't go to Starbucks I
don't drink coffee first of all he would
if they were semen though but when I
said that I know they're not going to
add that I know they're not going to
edit it I know that could put that on
there yeah
by giving your tides
I'm I'm tied into the goddamn
seeming as milk guy
I'd like to know what you're doing with
that money that's my church
there was a the last time I went to a
service in um
or a city in Maryland where my family
used to live
they went to this local church there and
one of the pat it was a small Church
Pentecostal the type of they like
speaking tongues and stuff like that
okay
um this pastor got up there and started
talking about in a room full of probably
35 people I mean there's not a lot of
people in this room I started talking
about how if you use an iPad you're
going to hell okay because technology is
like inherently of the devil and it's
leading us down the path of
non-righteousness and so then he said if
you've got an iPad you need to repent
and you need to pray every night you
don't burn in hell oh my God and I said
but I want to put on my iPad what about
if I want to play online that's when I
realized God didn't exist I don't know
if I can't play Flappy Bird I'm gonna
kill myself dude that theory is so
inconsistent though he's sitting there
with like pants and [ __ ] it's like you
don't believe in technology wearing
pants no no
you got here on a motor vehicle probably
made in a machine
yeah yeah I remember and I was probably
like 15 and I was like
me reading fan fiction in the background
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
so was everyone pretty receptive to that
though no we all went to Golden Corral
afterward and as a family we were like
yeah yeah he's a little crazy
was he this crazy no this is crazy don't
argue with me
milk mammary glands semen
both are naturally produced by the body
and a lot of people tend to like them
his argument is that anything produced
by the body is good and should be eaten
and tasting anything produced by the
body should go in a Starbucks drink a
lot of people tend to like them they
like it they like it not me wow I've
never tasted semen in my life basically
saying he did and he likes it he loves
it
I'm not gay
I just like when men come in my mouth I
love the smell of balls the taste of
balls ropes I like the ropes I like the
way it feels in my hand that's insane I
am gay
that's Cuomo
I didn't recognize that one yeah did you
know that we got one of Cuomo he did the
same thing where he goes I'm a New
Yorker oh I die I
am black I am gay I am disabled
I'm disabled that's so good oh do the
Qatari one
and today I feel uh Qatari today I feel
disabled today I feel uh gay
people he got pissed that people were
like yo why are you having FIFA and
Qatar uh uh because they're like
literally traffic and human beings and
I'm slaves and he's like stop bullying
Qatar today I feel gay
and then play fouseytubes uh you know
Fouseytube yeah here which was worthless
I felt ugly I felt gained
like that just based on what they told
me that was just accepted speech at an
award show worthless
ugly and gay yeah period oh [ __ ] it's so
good
yeah and then one more play um
play uh uh trumps
I'm obsessed with you having these on a
roll over
so it's the best acceptance speech ever
we sent an impersonator to these
Streamys this year and we wanted to have
him do this exception speech about I
knew I was gonna win though they hate me
please
they can't have a winner be banned on
two different platforms yeah exactly
first off I want to dedicate this award
to the dof rubber as the best family on
YouTube his muscles Rippling out of his
shirt one of the most hated YouTubers on
the platform
that's maybe because I let ricegum punch
me in the face or maybe because I came
out and said 99 of the pranks on YouTube
are fake but I want to say this for a
long time I looked at myself in the
mirror and I based myself based on what
I read on the comments I felt worthless
I felt ugly I felt gay
that's based on what they told me and
then they got to like that it's
important words that I had to use for
myself whenever I was fighting my mental
is that great
[Music]
no and he's so [ __ ] for serious too
oh yeah yeah that's insane worthless I
felt ugly I felt gay I felt that nobody
told me
the most important words of my life
that's awesome oh he's getting used for
myself whenever I was fighting my mental
illness those two words are I am because
every day when I looked at myself in the
mirror I reminded myself I am powerful I
am strong I am confident I am beautiful
I am worthy I am straight I am beyond
this is definitely straight so every
night I wanted to quit because one of
the comments was telling me that I
should leave YouTube for whatever reason
I believed in myself beauty isn't what
we have on the outside but it's who we
are as a person on the inside he knows
he's losing as long as we all Embrace
and believe that in ourselves
how beautiful we all are on the outside
I'm happy and proud to be in the room
with all of you guys right now a lot of
you look so confused I love all of you
guys thank you so much
pretty incredible stuff
wow hey look at that
that's us oh I love doing this let's see
here yeah I remember we watched that
that was fun yeah that was a good memory
yeah it was a great time I'm proud to be
in the room with those clips of us
talking about from the first episode of
us talking about [ __ ] in a Starbucks
cup
with Copans I still to this day when I'm
sad I'll go back and watch those people
I love that actually since you mentioned
that I do have some Tick Tock stuff I
wanted to show you we spent so much time
oh Jesus Christ
let's see um
here's one if they're here I have some
alpha male stuff
I don't know if you know this but I
became like
the focus of alpha male Tick Tock I
became super viral
for me being the ultimate soy watch this
[ __ ]
Life's too short to exercise I'm just
gonna be honest there are so many better
things to do than exercise it is a shame
I'm seeing the Beauty and the strength
[Music]
yeah the soy Destroyer all right
yeah so this became like a full on alpha
male meme has never felt the loving and
warm touch of a woman I I don't care bro
it's all about the Bros
for using me what I said about
exercising and uh
I love it get the [ __ ] game spend
five hours in the gym every day exercise
three times a day from this instant time
they really trying to do something with
this vowed to stop disappointing
Yourself by the way Bucky is like some
weird anime muscle fetish [ __ ] okay it's
like funny I like it I've watched it but
it's not great it's a little bit weird
yeah decide to be extraordinary and do
what you need to do let's see it now let
me see them to reality wait this is a
bakkie
foreign
[Applause]
wow by the way that guy looks like like
dude you need to get your life a little
bit more together before you make fun of
me that is um
they are so out of touch with reality I
ended them yeah and be the person that
makes these [ __ ] edits I wish I could
be in that mindset for like a day what's
interesting is that people these
actually get a lot of views people love
these
people look bro are they all like l303
yeah yeah yeah
I want to look at his bathroom first
because he's calling me a loser and I'm
not trying to say God damn it tick tock
I'm not trying to say anything but
that dude lives I mean he lives with his
parents for sure good for him
it's understandable yeah well he's a
[ __ ] loser I don't live with my
parents I don't care how old he is
so L here let's see the comments I want
to see the comments oh this went hard
he fell off about me
yeah he finished so out of touch with
reality nowadays it's sad
yes sir no mid mindset here what are you
outside
outside go sunbathe you know they're
going to turn this into a bakkie edit
now
sitting with them
there is no greater crime than a man who
doesn't drink his own semen
coming in a cup of Starbucks coffee
that's the alpha [ __ ] that we need right
[ __ ] it now look at that that's what I'm
into right I need an alpha to come come
on my big mac oh my God they're gonna
clip this for sure
why would someone say that oh no they're
agreeing with him to be honest exercise
is one of the most fun and productive
things you can do
good for you bro negativity bro he likes
to be little others for exercising since
he has given up on training on multiple
occasions by the way I never I was
literally just joking around like it's
crazy bro you really because this is
what it is you attacked these men's sole
purpose yeah their sole purpose is to be
ripped as [ __ ] yeah and you just said
that actually doesn't matter and now
there's like spiraling because it's like
they don't know who they are they used
to love me too I used to love Ethan so
sad so then he got fat period damn right
this chill this quote gave me chills bro
I'm so sad to hear h3h we say that yo
I'm like literally laughing there's
people laughing when I say it wait God
is this not a go down
is this not him in the video it is no
scroll down scroll down
so there's a comment that says thanks
bro
and then someone said no go down more
uh one more time when we're done we're
done thanks bro thanks King no worries
is that him in the video I think he's
just saying thanks for the Epic vid if
this was an edit of another man that was
going to be so wait hold on hold on
they're not the same oh damn I was so
excited look look at 6-1 band it's in
his profile aesthetic engineer
[Music]
bio
aesthetic engineering AKA unemployed
yeah so there's there's a lot I'm
enjoying this let's keep going we
literally have a gym in our studio
treadmill an hour every day
Life's too short to exercise I'm just
gonna be honest there's so look at this
guys like excuses facts dude you can
show off your muscles without like
okay no no you can't you're right Life's
too short to exercise I'm just gonna be
honest there's so many better things
Jesus Christ without
[Music]
out of leading himself
inside of you there are two wolves one
is a furry the other inside of you are
two holes one on your dick and one on
your head
try to tuck one into the other
both of them are pro-labs
prolapses they require any way to
masculinity a real man will prolapse his
ass that's too short yeah let's see what
this guy you used to be funny now you're
just cringe oh no he's talking to me
it's got 140 000 likes I'm saying these
people there's a lot of exercise I'm
just gonna be honest there are so many
better things to do about exercise it is
I'm seeing the beauty and strength of
which his body is capable
we can someone edit fart noises
you used to be funny now you're cringe I
wonder if he's looking in the mirror and
this is what he thinks
here let's try it again
[Music]
it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty of this body
is capable we literally replayed this
for the party I thought it was at the
drop show Kim the gym in our studio
[ __ ] it up can't thank you
yeah y'all haters we literally have a
gym in our studio you hate her ass
[ __ ] losers look at this
every damn day here
so look how much good is done for cam
I'm still working on my bulk but I'll
get there eventually yeah we believe in
you because it's a shame for a man to
not see the maximum capacity I want to
read another one of those quotes you
have another quote one
um let's see I'm looking Life's too
short to exercise
it is a shame for us
on stumps steroids right here
you know what's interesting I eat
hamburgers and I my veins look the same
it's kind of a it's kind of an
interesting thing
it's my favorite because I'm not sure at
first I wasn't sure if it was real or
not it was meant to be a joke I think
we're both equally as close to heart
attack yeah that is he is you don't know
if it's a joke not that one I'm saying
number seven after this oh seven yeah
cool yeah no they're all the same Ethan
used to be funny and now he's fat so I
hate him
facts
there's so many better things to do than
exercise it is a shame I know this guy's
for real yeah at first I wasn't sure but
yeah as it plays on I'm like yeah wait
are you sure because he went viral for
looking like a rose no but he's actually
he took that and then so and turn I
don't know if he's an Intel but he's
like a fitness instructor now like he
took that [ __ ] all the way damn yeah
everybody
[Music]
let's get it it is a shame for a man
that they all accepted like being so
shallow yeah like anybody else with any
hobby or whatever it is that they're
super good at can you imagine them just
shaming everyone else no I can draw
really good look at all you losers you
cannot draw
that's so weird so this one has almost
600 000 likes that's crazy this is a
segment like a section of the internet
that I just never interact with like I
don't even know it exists well the only
reason I don't think any girls interact
with this I think guys doing it for
other guys this is absolutely guys
performing that humility for other men
yeah I think they're impressing other
men I don't think girls like no it's a
big circle these are dudes whose dads
never hug them and they don't know how
to express their feelings like their
masculinity means closing off and also
drinking semen it's another type of meal
like when I when I see this [ __ ] come
across my feed it's like in a
post-ironic your cringe with yeah yeah I
feel like I follow a bunch of meme
accounts on Instagram and when it makes
it to those accounts I'm like period
This is a cringe piece of art you know
no these are all serious oh yeah liver
King came on the show
and they made this awesome edit makes it
look like he's cut me a position because
you're so big and sometimes fat guys
have a problem they have to they have to
go into a certain position I mean your
master what position do you have to go
in position
here's the thing
um never talk about my wife
[Music]
what's funny is like people our fans
were joking about how unfazed I was by
totally that is so [ __ ] that was so
funny extremely rare liver King I
thought they liked him
stupendously rare liver King dub go to
the replies of those comments I want to
see the war wait what's happening why
don't why didn't they like liver King
common with liver King he's just his
wife
but this is old no but this comments
aren't new it's from November 6th
November 6th yeah and that's pretty
smoking yeah we're in December nine it's
free all the drama the interviewer was
asking for his own fantasy good answer
for your own fan fiction yeah
anyway it's funny
this whole [ __ ] corner of the
internet is so weird
I would [ __ ] I would literally you
don't want to know what I'd do to
Vatican City for a club
[Laughter]
I would hand out pamphlets about how
great they are and I love the church
okay okay
we'll get your coffee
thank you
um
let's see what else
we got that oh here I want to show you
this guy okay
you want life and scars or dark
psychology dark psychology
we're gonna watch both I'm sorry you
gotta you got a minute
I'm gonna blast through these okay
because I don't want to keep you here
forever I'll stay here all night okay
good then we're just gonna be here okay
how to control your woman
profit this is why you're a women no no
this shit's serious control your women
are you kidding me what does that even
mean Art of Seduction manipulation
psychological
man so it's called metal power
I don't know it's an alpha thing so they
say profit from their menstrual period
what does that even mean what here days
one through seven are the days of their
period day 7 through 12 are the greatest
times to complement them but do not
express any kind of emotion
the horniest are Days 12 to 16. the best
time to manipulate them is now why since
day 16 to 21 are the days they are most
open to manipulation girl
manipulation what is he planning what
does that even mean
just to trick them into having sex with
them I guess to join his army
I thought I thought these guys are their
plan is to be hot and actually get women
why does he need them well yeah it's
funny that they all want to be hot and
desirable but then at the same time they
need to trip women to sleeping with them
starving Tyler Durden by the way
who and I've watched that movie I don't
remember him like yeah so when did Brad
Pitt ever talk about controlling women's
mentals like never that's I missed that
part of that movie I think he just
wanted to like be with his homies okay I
see that
yeah this is nuts and look at this is
like a sexy Brad Pitt scene they just
want to [ __ ] dudes bro and that's cool
literally like sexy Brad Pitt moment no
they want to be him and also look at how
they talk about women and the way it's
written it's like they're talking about
some animal that is in a cage somewhere
literally look at this [ __ ] the serial
killer from country for no men okay how
to be cold
this has likes dude I like this [ __ ]
pay no attention to how other people are
feeling why would you need an instructor
on how to be a psychopath what
you either got it or you don't please
is it just music yeah it's just music
always
believe you are superior to others but
don't say it out loud
you should only think about yourself
the person who's so pathetic they need
information on how to be a psychopath
you know that book that's like how to
manipulate people
48 rules of power or whatever okay yeah
I read somewhere online which is
probably false um but if you're like
buying that book they kind of put you
historically like when you read it from
a library on the same group of people
like if you're renting mineconf if
you're renting any of these like
Communist Manifesto any of these books
it's like traditional it's like why are
you yeah why are you trying to
manipulate and control people why are
you looking at self-help books you're
cringe bro you're [ __ ] cringe this is
how to be cold this is so lame be in
control your emotions become stoic
display no emotions
what do you gain from this why do you
want to be this and we're so comfortable
no one wants to hang out with you yeah
cool you're insufferable to be around
yeah we all have a group chat without
you we're texting about you in that room
because you are being very cold
yo you ever hang out with Aaron he's so
[ __ ] stoic and emotional golden stuff
that's cool God he's so hot oh I wonder
when he's gonna bring his gun to school
so first let's learn how to be cold and
then how to manipulate women because
they don't want to be around us we're
cold by the way oh let's go Henry Cavill
you have to bring Superman into a
notoriously nice guy right right
notoriously hot lady killer like female
gays Henry apparently they're using him
for some reason because they want to
[ __ ] him if you're talking to a group of
girls then avoid Target and compliment
the rest neg your target haha your nose
Wiggles when you laugh and point it out
to the other girls if you lower a girl's
self-esteem traffic validation
oh my God this is disturbing and she'll
end up chasing you no [ __ ] way
look at this top comment that's so not
this is such a guy who wrote this yeah
it does work top comment as a woman
myself and I also have a vagina this
does work there
the tits are bouncing it does work
actually you know what uh I'll show you
who actually who's running this Tick
Tock video I see it and these are like
not small right no no this one is 100
200 000 likes oh my area God no and all
the comments are like this is real this
works oh wait what's his name hold on
you guys this is it'll be worth it what
is happening to society but this is such
a sub like
subculture of a subculture it feels like
online where these hyper actually Maddie
Healy has a good rant about this which
you might agree with this
there's such a like distinction between
the right and the left when it comes to
masculinity on the left like oh I found
the author that the outlook's about
right he's 16. no yeah ultimate
gentleman you remember that
showed up a bunch of frat houses at UCSB
because you can get laid and he said I'm
the ultimate gentleman why don't women
want to be with me it's not fair he's
he's a shooter and he's out of prison no
he's dead no holy die yeah you posted a
bunch of videos online holy [ __ ]
that's an old meme he's he was a meme
for a while the ultimate gentleman oh no
I didn't know anything about that
yeah so sorry Henry who got roped into
this but what were you
yeah so there's this whole thing Maddie
Healy does this rant at his shows that I
completely agree with and he says that
when you think about it in the right and
the left for the left this like woke man
that paints his fingernails and like
wears dresses and whatever right there's
no like mold for that type of person
because you're either what you're gay
because you wear a dress or you're still
a manipulator because you see what women
want and you do that and you still
manipulate them versus on the right
these sort of people create a clear
here's 12 steps on how to become a
masculine man and like it gives you a
sense of identity in your masculinity
and that's the difference between like
so many young vulnerable men fall into
that trap of being like an alt-right boy
because the archetype is so clearly
formed and the mold is so formed and
then on the left you know it's like how
do you be a liberal woke man there's
really no archetype other than what
Harry Styles we don't know what Harry
Styles is really like you know I mean
like we know the idealized version that
we want him to be but there's no like
spokesman for the for the liberal left I
mean not for well I think they're the
Traditional Values go hand in hand with
conservatism so these guys who want to
be traditional masculine men it's just
yeah they're just tried and true yeah
you know what it looks like but on the
left you don't know what that looks like
you know to be a healthy man who has a
healthy relationship with the women in
his life you know there's there's not an
archetype for that and I think that's a
Maddie talks about that on tour and it's
funny because Henry Cavill as far as I'm
aware is like
super masculine dude nice sure who is
that the Superman oh that guy yeah that
they were showing and yeah
let's see rather than asking a straight
follow-up question when you're
interacting with somebody
constantly repeat back anything they
previously stated oh my God the term for
this is isopraxism that will talk longer
and tell more details without realizing
you are listening thanks to this oh
that's just that's like a nice listening
advice maybe how to be an active
listener yeah Ryan Gosling manipulated
got you got you to open up to me prank
got you to further the bond between us
gay
you're literally gay people in the chat
are saying that Hassan is um what you're
describing
what about me guys Hassan is the female
fantasy
for a lot not for me not for me for a
lot of women online definitely
uh what about Ethan clients yeah uh
hello what about Ethan Klein well Ethan
Klein
hello
all right do we have another ultimate
Caitlyn
someone's saying Ultra masculine
I think you and Oliver together are the
ideal man one one full man we could yeah
more life and scars this guy gives
really practical life advice for example
how to stop beating your meat how to
stop drinking your dick
compilations oh so yeah this is his
channel um life and scars yeah he's just
he's been through it and he's just
telling it like it is I go send you this
hold on we can pull it up I had to stop
beating your meat
you play it I want to hear I want to
hear what you check your dick is because
of boredom and assets you might just be
hanging around the house and you're bump
into the kitchen table or you could be
sitting on the couch watching TV and
you're scratching nuts boondados can
cause your dick to get hard and so
you'll look down and you'll be like well
since we're here now
stop thinking like that leave that dick
alone and when it comes to access on
these social media sites y'all ain't
following nothing but badass [ __ ] and
every time you log into Instagram or
something you'll see a [ __ ] doing some
jumping jacks or twerking and you did
get hard and you'll think well I might
as well go to the hub and finish it out
unfollow these [ __ ] change your
mindset
um Black Friday about to come up y'all
and everybody else is getting all the
good advertisements on the electronics
the TVs and [ __ ] you're getting
advertisements on dick pills Google
knows you next time you feel like you
need to jack your dick I want you to
grab the head of your dick and the base
of your dick twist one hand to the right
one hand to the left go back and forth
to your Learning lesson game is game
an assets
okay can you pull it up oh
no I don't
all right Ethan is grabbing his phone
he's on Tick Tock live right now
uh follow Ethan on Tick Tock if you
don't follow him already
okay
[Music]
Ethan apparently you're as the celebrity
pass for some people here in the chat
nice
[Music]
female gays I didn't approve that pass
[Laughter]
es Elizabeth to fist fight every single
person in the chat
[Music]
I do the [ __ ] podcast guy figure it
out what are you trying to figure out
can I airdrop it to Dan
it's a video it's a screen recording uh
Dan doesn't have airdrop I have airdrop
or drop a baby all right while you do
that let's learn about the Houdini sex
move
trust me like you're saying you're one
not a Houdini a [ __ ]
wait hold on you gotta you gotta learn
how to Houdini a [ __ ] maybe if you see
it or uh yeah that's good
we're in business
all right this is important how many
YouTubers okay I'm focusing how to
Houdini a [ __ ]
there's two ways to do
a sex move the first way is that you
[ __ ] somebody from behind and right
before you're about to nut you pull your
dick out and you spit on their back
right towards that [ __ ] stamp area it's
gonna create an illusion they gonna
think that you've done and then they're
gonna turn around and that's when you
just bust that nut in their face that is
in Spain
that is actually the craziest thing I've
ever heard
that what
it's a little magic a little time
trouble magic
that is um we gotta hear that again you
know what this is elevated thinking
we're just now this is the Houdini
because you really need to bust on her
face when you really need to bust it on
her face but she doesn't want you to
Jesus Christ not a Houdini a [ __ ] what
y'all there's two ways to do the Houdini
it's a sex movie first way is that you
[ __ ] somebody from behind and right
before you go about the nut you pull
your dick out and you spit on their back
try to aim towards that [ __ ] stamp area
it's gonna create an illusion they're
gonna think that you've done and then
they're gonna turn around and that's
when you just bust that nail in their
face y'all they're gonna be amazing
and showing his face
for that one I love his like light up
aquarium in the background yeah super
cool if you are ever fortunate enough to
be in a position to be having sex with a
woman
make sure here's what I want you to do
make sure to disrespect them in every
minute on them and then and then
surprise come in their eyes make sure to
make it a little magic low magic
make sure to wear a robe now the next
way is the second one after Houdini
because he's known for being a great
escape artist however I think this [ __ ]
is illegal almost everywhere
okay so he gets it that's good okay he's
like but that's not gonna stop us is it
Buzz
consent then you're good to go so I go
like this you get somebody on the bed so
you're saying you guys consent gotta get
consent okay oh is that what he said
hold on let me go back yeah
however I think this [ __ ] is illegal
almost everywhere but if you get consent
then you're good to go okay if you get
consent then it's not the who then why
are you yeah then why are you tricking
he's just saying this for the for the
judge okay like this you get somebody on
the bed [ __ ] them in doggy style in
front of a window had a window open so
they could see out of it in the middle
of [ __ ] them you just gonna pull your
dick out and you're gonna tell them I'll
be right back stay just like that when
you walk out the room have somebody else
come in oh yeah that's illegal why they
in there [ __ ] that person you walk
out the house and you walk past the
window
it's gonna [ __ ] the whole world
I'm pretty sure it is so it's awful if
you understand that right yes you think
somebody else yeah someone comes and
then takes over and then he walks as the
window glow magic trick so sexual
assault yeah uh my favorite job so
that's the one that he says he thinks is
illegal holy [ __ ] yes so so how do we
get consent for that
how do you ask for that baby come on the
show and I just hate men well that's
kind of what we do here wow
here's Brittany's uh yeah I'll play the
this is the um this is the discography
his discography oh he has the greatest
hits yes his Greatest Hits okay how to
turn a [ __ ] into an angry dragon
the number one way to meet some [ __ ]
how to sneak out the house how to steam
engine a [ __ ] one of the best hobbies
to have as a cheater is for how to do
the hamburger with your dick in your
balls try to get some head look how to
get some head
how the [ __ ] a sick woman I'd have sent
a big old big piece
how to [ __ ] your girl with your fingers
guys I value these nuts across your chin
[ __ ] your girlfriend's mama guys whoa
you want to stick your dick in something
that's not human well whoa you don't
understand that we ain't [ __ ] yeah
yeah he's basically like his version of
like fiction like fanfiction my favorite
is
and nobody asked for that I guarantee
I just said do you want to [ __ ]
something that's not human yeah
the joking
at least a little bit like how to
Hamburger your dick
my favorite is flu season
[ __ ] a sick woman I think it's clickbait
this is his version of clickbait because
there's no thumbnails on Tick Tock when
you're scrolling so he's gotta hook you
I think [ __ ] something isn't alive I
think he was right I think this is male
fanfic it is had a dick how to tuck your
dicks into your own balls and then come
to your mouth
what the [ __ ] your own mama
this is the helpful information that
young straight yes we need
how to
how to obtain date rape drugs like
pick your dick in something that's not
human well well I don't understand that
we ain't [ __ ]
how to do the bird bad with your ball
sack so you don't got caught cheating
now you can gotta get some [ __ ] if you
a short dude I don't know some bad
coochie when you see it true how to do
the back win with your nutsack bro this
this man's like a nut tree
he's like okay
[Laughter]
what is it called the trapeze yeah this
is different shapes can you make that
week is that
this is him dude this is this is this is
our boy
trapeze from your nuts out boys
you boys gonna want to grab you by the
nut sack
one of the best hobbies to have as a
cheater is how to make your partner deep
throat you look you know why you ain't
getting no [ __ ] because you doing a lot
of the same [ __ ] that these females are
doing
outside with some bad kids
I'm gonna get a [ __ ] using coloring
books what the [ __ ] happened to my
channel
my shadow badge
you just you just basically explain how
to rape a woman in 30 different ways and
he's like why my channel is pedal I only
have a hundred thousand followers damn
how to date somebody with some bad ass
kids what I get a [ __ ] using coloring
books look fellas what the [ __ ] happened
to my channel this is why your balls
think
he's awesome I thought it's kind of
everything he is the moment holy [ __ ]
this guy I would be so much happier if
this guy was the role model not Andrew
Tate because he snuck in some stuff in
there that was like man we ain't [ __ ]
yes he's he's self-aware he's like men
how to get a job
how to move out of your mom's house how
to make your bed in the morning man
just flipping in really good advice how
to prepare good meals at home how to
iron a shirt yes and then how do
[Laughter]
you how to do it with your nutsack
oh my god oh my god dude he's awesome
how to get a [ __ ] with a coloring book
I had a bit that one's great
I actually you wanna know that word
information
all right that's everything damn guys we
did it
what haven't we done we've done it all
I've seen just about enough I'll be
honest I need to go home and stare at a
[ __ ] wall
if you want us to send you the prolapse
video or not can you airdrop that I know
it's a long time can you airdrop that
tour
hey I wouldn't worry about it I would
not worry about it in the slide totally
fine
[Music]
well
um thank you so much for the so nice to
see you [ __ ] snack
it was fun though so nice to see you it
was such a good time I hope we'll get
together again soon yes in the New Year
2023 guys weird right there
sounds weird when you're closer to death
poor I'm dying at 64. so
enjoy it all right next time post
Malone's gonna be here too
so without working on that
and uh he will okay I'm not even gonna
make it gross yeah I'll work on that
yeah don't all right thanks for watching
everybody on Monday or no so we won't be
here on Monday reminder but we will be
doing the show on Tuesday because we'll
be celebrating Ila's birthday 29.
oh there's new BTS online for members by
the way
I also wanted to make a quick
announcement that the Tuesday episode
will continue the members only episode
will continue through the break thank
you I'll talk more about that later
and dedicated King you know what it is
all right guys love y'all have a great
weekend it's Friday baby [ __ ] in my
[ __ ] armpit and mash it into [ __ ]
butter
[ __ ]
yeah one more before we go [ __ ] yeah
baby this is what human growth hormones
[ __ ] you [ __ ] them no yo he eats Chinese
food with those nipples
all right oh Lord that was disturbing
actually
guys thank you uh we'll see you next
week on Tuesday have a great weekend
everybody love you bye
thank you
foreign
[Music]